capital à mali capitale du mali capitale
du mali niamey
ça c'est une chanson sénat pouilles à
magna mais n'avait attention pour la
musique et le sud
[Musique]
r
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
non
[Musique]
chers amis chers ennemis
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle l'émission qui fait
avec nous ce soir jerry jean-pierre
l'émulation souhaiterait bien de taïwan
[Musique]
judith godrèche de mofilm nouvelle vie
bruno solo yvan le bolloc'h
à nouveau c'est nouvelle lui
d'après ces johnson captieux
[Musique]
le procès nouvelle vie
le chanteur de depeche mode
ça craint livrade avant
pas des litiges
environnement formidable
leblanc dommage que philipp bandi
allons-y
[Musique]
on a vu
l'inégalable non ma fille
tu commences avalant très bien et toi tu
irais ça va très bien parce que la
semaine dernière on a fait à peu près
notre score habituel face à la star
academy merci aux intermittents merci
aux intermittents
bon pour que de le devenir un terreau
notre émission là non parce qu'elle a
enregistré voix ont pour avantage vaut
mieux l'interrompt projette son
directeur
bienvenue aussi parlé des villas et
l'allemagne les deux jeunes filles
voilées d'aubervilliers j'ai reçu de
nombreux mails les concernant bah
écoutez tout le monde en parle c'est
l'émission où tout le monde peut parler
voilà donc je donne la parole à tout le
monde même si je suis pas toujours
d'accord avec eux et j'ai une devise que
j'ai déjà expliqué ici c'est je ne
partage pas vos idées mais je suis prêt
à mourir pour que vous puissiez les
exprimer voilà c'est voltaire kalisa
j'ai deux les dirty musique commencera
je vais finir le boulot les mecs là bah
ouais j'ai vu que la première fois ça
s'est bien passé mais c'était super tout
le monde nous a fait les bons jours
comment ça va 2 les vous allez faire
quoi aujourd'hui ouais moi je suis pas
si les bandes la ouais bon allez au
boulot
j'accueille maintenant thierry
jean-pierre
[Musique]
m
bonsoir bienvenue je vais taper cassis
bonsoir thierry jean pierre a aussi des
fans de la semaine dernière et était
trop épais dossier laurent thierry
jean-pierre ancien juge d'instruction
est devenu célèbre sous le nom de juge
jean-pierre au moment de la sphère urba
gracco donc du scandale du financement
du parti socialiste auteur de nombreux
best seller invoqua et député européen
au nom du parti démocratie libérale
d'alain madelin voilà alors que le livre
est publié chez robert laffont ça
s'appelle taiwan connection scandale et
meurtres au coeur de la république et
s'est consacré à la fameuse affaire des
frégates de taïwan dont on a déjà parlé
et christine deviers joncour et roland
dumas alors faire en gros l'histoire
malgré les accords qui lient la france à
la république populaire de chine
la france a vendu du matériel est la
chine nationaliste c'est à dire ex for
most taiwan et les gens qui ont permis
ce marché c'est normal ont reçu des
commissions c'est le c'est le cas à
chaque fois qu'il ya des démarches et
sur ce très importantes sur les armes
mais là ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'avec
des rétrocommissions c'est à dire que
l'argent est revenu en france une partie
de l'argent à venue en france et on
pense que ça alimenter la caisse d'un
certain nombre de partis politiques
alors c'est une grosse affaire parce que
5 milliards de francs évaporée et
pratiquement une dizaine de mains c'est
beaucoup huit morts 8 - oui et puis on
est loin de la corruption politique
classique
dans les années 90 au moment de la
sphère urbas le chiffre d'affaires du
rebond c'est quoi ces 100 millions de
francs ouais là on est pour un dossier à
cinq milliards devraient donc se démode
ce montant de commissions est absolument
énorme est assez courant dans le dans le
milieu de l'armement et ce qui est assez
courant aussi ce que j'ai découvert en
france cette enquête c'est les
règlements de compte ouais c'est
évidemment les affaires nationales mais
c'est aussi les assassinats commandités
et c'est pour ça que dans ce dossier
notamment il y à huit morts au moins un
est mort connu terne a beaucoup parlé de
l' affaire elf ou de la sphère du mas
mais par rapport à l' affaire des
frégates de taïwan c'est rien du tout on
peut même se demander on y viendra sans
doute si finalement la faire elle fait
la sphère d'humain ne sont pas des
diversions
organise et pour étouffer l affaire des
frégates de taïwan non je ne pense pas
parce que d'un point de vue financier
l'affairé elf aurait dû être s'il avait
été à son terme une énorme faim mais par
contre au niveau du disparition ouais au
niveau des incidents il est évident que
ça n'a pas de ça n'a pas de rapport
alors vous parlez de votre mystérieux
informateur thierry jean-pierre que vous
avez l'homme cigare je connais alors
peut-être plusieurs hommes ont peut-être
une femme enfant tous les cas évidemment
vous avez pas nous dire qui c'est qui
vous a balancé les les infos alors
reprendre les choses au départ au départ
mitterrand hésite il ya un accord avec
la chine populaire il ya une demande de
la chine nationaliste il ya deux clans
il yad'un côté roland dumas qui lui veut
pas vendre les frégates à taïwan et puis
un lobby pro taïwan avec chevènement
edith cresson jacques attali et
finalement mitterrand s'est pas très
bien quoi faire et pour décider du mage
les raisons qui a décidé du main c'est
que alfred sirven décide d'utiliser
christine deviers joncour la de
la république qui est censé faire
changer roland dumas d'avis c'est ça oui
oui c'est ça mais sachant que le réseau
sirven
devaient être payés mais à des
proportions finalement assez faible oui
puisque sur le 5 milliards 500 millions
de francs serrières bonjour oui
finalement alors le groupe de pression
s'organise et là il ya beaucoup de
voyages d'hommes politiques français à
taiwan jean-michel jeunes nés jean marie
le guen cambadélis strauss kahn marie
d'edith cresson est ce que vous croyez
qu'ils sont invités à taiwan mais qu'ils
sont bien traités pour pour les amener à
faire pression sur le président
mitterrand il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
français surtout à gauche d'ailleurs en
l'espèce qui est qu'ils arrivent à
taiwan et qui essaient de profiter
effectivement de la man 2
taiwan taiwan à l'époque et d'un des
pays les plus riches du monde 100
milliards de dollars de réserves et en
plus taiwan paie cash donc on veut tout
vendre à taiwan on veut vendre
synchrotron d un satellite un tgv métro
des grandes surfaces que sais-je encore
on veut tout vendre et dans le domaine
de l'armement tous les grands
industriels de l'armement se précipite à
taïwan de façon à essayer tout vendre et
au passage des commissions sont versés
et des rétrocommissions aurait en france
vient alors finalement roland dumas
finit par conseiller à françois
mitterrand de donner le feu vert à la
vente comment ça se fait qu'il change
d'avis comme ça brutalement après un
voyage à pékin justement c'est un voyage
à pékin avec quelques signes deviers
joncour donc on sait pas ce qui s'est
passé plein dans l'autre on revient sur
ses positions jouer c'est qu'elle te
dire il faudrait il faudrait lui poser
la question je crois que le plus après
alors roland roland dumas change d'avis
en fait ce qui va mettre le souk c'est
le refus de thomson qui vendait les
frégates à taïwan qui était le fabricant
le refus de thompson et son patron alain
gomes de payer les réseaux sirven qui
pourtant l'avait aidé et en fait si on
peut penser que si thomson avait payé ce
qui devait ainsi revel et 160 millions
de francs n'y aurait jamais eu
d'affaires elles furent jamais de faire
du mal et peut-être pas d' affaire des
frégates de taiwan deviendra le pari de
faire des frégates c'est soit il reste
assez étonnant de les voir se bagarrer
comme ça quand il ya un procès en suisse
devant un tribunal arbitral procès que
gagne sirven d'ailleurs aimé dont il ne
peut pas profiter parce qu'il part en
cavale en évidence que ouais ouais donc
il y aurait pas eu ce refus de thomson
de payer nous contribuables français on
n'aurait jamais rien su quoi
probablement pas ouais donc c'est à dire
qui a peut-être d'autres affaires comme
ça mais il y en a sur chaque gros
contrats d'armement est évidemment et en
écrivant ce bouquin ce qui est qui moi
m'a beaucoup surpris c'est de découvrir
un monde que je ne connaissais pas du
tout quand même assez extraordinaire
assez hallucinant où la vie ne vaut pas
grand chose il parle en milliards de
8000 euros et un contrat ça vaut un
petit contrat ça vaut 4 5000 euros
thierry par exemple si on veut supprimer
connu ces huit minois libye mais met
lever cinquante mille balles là il s'est
lui même pas cher et non ses pêcheurs et
et donc c'est quand même un univers
assez particulier alors dumas lui pour
se défendre effectivement il essaiera de
recentrer son histoire sur les sur les
milliards d'aidé frégate mais finalement
jamais la sphère ne remontera à la
surface d'une certaine façon jamais il
faudra que qui est une enquête en suisse
quand même un comble ouais la justice
viennent de suisse qui est une enquête
en suisse pour blanchiment les jours
berlin way pour qu'enfin le l'enquêté
ouverte en france alors eva joly et
laurence vichnievsky refusé d'instruire
le dossier alors qu'elle en aurait
instruit plein avec quelques ailes
amiens au nom dix thèses des intérêts
supérieurs de l'état ce qui est
totalement incompréhensible crois
qu'elle était totalement nubie leppard
humains épars et par l'affairé elle
ferait mais elles n'ont pas voulu ça
c'est clair s'occuper d'affaires de
frégates et le parquet de paris non plus
arranger tout le monde alors il faudrait
attendre le juge renaud van ruymbeke
donc pour qu'il ouvre une information
mais ces dix ans après les faits
pratique ni
wifi toutes les enquêtes sur les sur les
assassinats commis un assassinat
comment enquêter sur un assassinat main
à taïwan pour le coup autant donner
après les faits alors quand on veut
savoir qui a touché ce pognon parce
qu'il ya quand même un paquet là pour le
coin on répond secret défense voilà oui
on répond secret défense et sert c'est
aussi c'est une particularité
franco française à dire on est le seul
pays quasiment 6 avec l'italie de
berlusconi on est le seul pays dans le
domaine demande occidentale à confondre
le secret défense est le secret des flux
financiers c'est à dire on dit non
seulement le secret défense c'est le
secret de la fabrication des vedettes
des avions des bateaux etc mais c'est
aussi les flux financiers douteux et
c'est aussi l'argent des corrompus c'est
ceci aussi bien à droite qu'à gauche on
dira c'est laurent fabius qui dit non je
ne devrais pas le secret défense et puis
aujourd'hui il ya quelques mois c'est
francis mer qui dit non je lèverai pas
le secret défense qui offrent également
non seulement ils lèvent pas le secret
défense mais en plus ils étendent aux
problèmes financiers ouais parce que
c'est pas seul à cpnt son armement une
question de pognon là évidemment aimé ça
veut dire non mais c'est très important
dire que laurent fabius d'abord
et mr ensuite 10 on ne veut pas qu'ils
aient denquête sur cette affaire et pour
toutes les affaires de ventes d'armes ça
va être la même chose ça va être la même
chose aujourd'hui les taiwanais sont en
train d'enquêter sur un autre dossier
qui est celui des mirages way et celui
des missiles vendus par matra à taïwan
quand le dossier arrivera en france en
mai dire la même chose mais n'ira secret
défense et sur l' affaire des frégates
il y a aujourd'hui dans un coffre la
direction générale des douanes ya un
feuillet avec 19 noms est ce que ce
feuillet est évidemment frappé par le
secret défense alors que sont le nom ce
sont là les noms des intermédiaires des
bénéficiaires et ça c'est les
commissions de tension c'est le joker de
la république ça à l'époque pas squad
pour l'emmerder lisa secret défense pour
le rainbow océan c'était pareil sauf que
là c'est une question de pognon c'est
pas une question de défense bien sûr
c'est une question de c'est uniquement
ça c'est pour protéger les bénéficiaires
de rétrocommissions qui sommes dès
qu'ils sont des hommes et des femmes
politiques français qui ont perçu
l'argent j'avais une idée vous de qui ça
peut être oui j'ai une idée mais je ne
suis pas le dire la haye pourquoi mais
juste un nom de famille n'ont rien du
tout même pas après n'engagent à rien tu
dire pourquoi c'est grave je veux dire
pourquoi c'est grave parce que là on
voit par exemple dans la sphère de
l'assurance american exécutif life c'est
les français c'est les contribuables
français qui vont devoir payer les
conneries des mecs qui ont acheté cette
compagnie d'assurance états unis et la
serre c'est nous qui allons payer au
lieu de faire des crèches des hôpitaux
et dernier lieu d'habitat oui mais là en
l'occurrence c'est pareil taïwan va
demander des comptes j'imagine mais il
est entre mes taiwan gens demander des
comptes voilà la navy dijon pays et qui
va payer c'est nous qui allons payer
parce que j'ai des coups mais aussi des
contribuables mais parce que je veux pas
faire de poujadisme à la petite semaine
enfin je crois quand même insensé que
dans deux cas consécutif la sphère
d'exécutif lac et maintenant la sphère
des frégates de taïwan ce soient les
contribuables français qui sont obligés
de payer parce que des mecs se sont
beaux et les fouilles à la mémé c'est
pire que ça parce que là non seulement
non seulement la france va devoir payer
parce qu'il a un contrat secret que je
révèle dans le bouquin va devoir payer
700 millions d'euros
à cause de ce sinistre là mais en plus
les sommes qui ont été saisies en suisse
sur les comptes d'un intermédiaire il a
été saisi 800 millions de dollars 800
millions de dollars
la justice suisse va être obligé de
restituer ces sommes à l'intermédiaire
parce que le dossier en france qui est
suivi par van ruymbeke va probablement
faire l'objet d'un non lieu et que donc
l' affaire de blanchiment s'arrêter
alors où sont passés les milliards alors
il ya quand même des rumeurs vous dites
voilà ça aurait servi à financer les
campagnes présidentielles en 95
qu'on m'a raconté mais vraiment de
première main l'homme au cigare non
c'est pas l'homme au cigare c'est
quelqu'un d'autre on m'a raconté que à
l'occasion des campagnes présidentielles
il y avait un des types des grandes
entreprises nationales qui était chargé
de faire la tournée des grands ducs une
fois par mois et qui avait régulièrement
donc une fois par mois quand ils
allaient dans les différents sièges ou
chez les différents hommes et femmes
politiques qui touchait il avait un
coffre de voiture dans le fond était
tapissé de liasses de billets de 500
francs les billets de 500 francs à
l'époque il en balade et un mètre cube
tous les mois c'est vous dire quel
argent liquide circulé à l'époque donc
évidemment il ya les suspicions de
financement occulte mais évidemment
apparemment si ça fait pas plus de
vagues ça c'est que la droite et la
gauche ont touché les deux sinon l'un
balancerait l'autre évidemment que la
droite et la gauche ont touché voilà
évidemment une connivence qui est qui
est absolument insupportable parce que
finalement là comme dans la sphère du
crédit lyonnais s'est évidemment notre
argent qui est en cause c'est nous qui
payons nos factures aubry c'est nous qui
en plus encore une fois c'est de
l'argent qui servira pas autre chose
il faudrait lever le secret défense à la
seule solution pour le moment c'est la
coopération avec des magistrats
étrangers qui ne sont pas soumis au
secret défense donc ça perraudin par
exemple en suisse perdent hommes et ce
qui est incroyable dans ce dossier c'est
que les ya une coopération judiciaire
entre taiwan et vaille avec la suisse
avec le luxembourg avec le liechtenstein
et avec le grand cayman un an qu'elle
manque quand même une des places fortes
du blanchiment elle est qu'ils coopèrent
dans ce dossier est le seul pays à pas
coopéré passé la france qui refuse les
commissions rogatoires avec taiwan et
avec les autres pays c'est totalement
hallucinant alors la seule solution
c'est quoi c'est l'opinion publique
c'est pour ça que j'avais facebook ah
oui mais oui bien sûr c'est l'opinion
publique c'est ce qu'on a fait les gens
90 l'époque personne ne voulait parler
de financement occulte de partis
politiques ou de corruption politique et
les juges ont réussi à faire sauter le
verrou mais avec une seule arme qui
alarme de l'opinion donc il va falloir
le faire là dessus
d'abord parce qu'il faut résoudre ses
problèmes de disparition des assassinats
vous trouver les coupables vous trouvez
les bénéficiaires des commissions et
puis ensuite parce que j'ai beaucoup
voyagé pour ce bouquet rhin et et la
france à l'étranger maintenant une
réputation de république bananière à
cause de son système de rétrocommissions
qui mis en place depuis une vingtaine
d'années et c'est obsolète supporter
sérieusement parce que vous me faites
penser un peu à d'aubert qui se bat
depuis des années contre la mafia contre
le blanchiment etc il est très courageux
de françois d'aubert mais il n'est pas
arrivé à grand chose est-ce que vous
avez pas peur finalement d'y passer
votre vie et que ce soit un petit peu le
pot de terre contre le pot de fer on est
arrivé à plein de choses il ya plein de
choses et notamment à voir par exemple
une cour pénale internationale qui
aurait imaginé sans les états unis 1
mais qui aurait imaginé il ya quinze ans
une cour pénale internationale donc on
irait mais ces changements là se font à
l'échelle d'une génération est pas de l
epa de 10 ans vous pensez qu'un jour on
saura la vérité sur cette affaire des
frégates on va y arriver mais c'est
tellement scandaleux qu'on vous êtes
confiant oui parce que je suis optimiste
de nature sinon je le ferai pas le
louper un merci merci ciel et
jean-pierre taiwan kitchen c'est certain
la faune
[Musique]
à qui
ouais
et maintenant qu'ils mettent leur
élément
oh
voici julie le gars brèche
je n'adore dans cyrus est une habituée
judith de tout le monde en parle où on
vous aime parce que vous êtes à la fois
sexy et romantique cochonnet romandie le
yin et yang
la innocente le lot leur butin à
les machos à la tout de suite non
c'est moi je suis mais lui il est
formidable
alors là il ya un nouveau ville pas oui
non pas marie et non mais non pas d'un
mari célibataire toujours toujours
célibataire open bar car apprendre
poperen barcares à prendre non c'est un
nouveau film ouais tu me comédie alors
c'est vrai au départ j'étais un petit
peu l'égérie de doillon d'assayas de
filières tout ça avec ridicule vous êtes
devenu une vraie actrice le droit de
avoir donné une fausse ridicule ça a été
la consécration j'ai le droit de jouer
dans la cour des grands et maintenant
vous vous amusez alors êtes-vous fait
tout ça avec beaucoup de plaisir j'ai un
petit côté la comtesse de paris je pas
si vous avez connu la comtesse de paris
elle avait écrit un livre qui s'appelait
tous mes bonheurs cucul la praline qua
non non non j'ai dit non non non non
match aller jeudi de gbich oui ça
l'est roberge si tu peux me tais tu dors
un peu non je m'en branle j'accepte ça
c'est bien je suis ailleurs fait d'un
moine de test
elle avait décidé de
attaquez-vous persie
c'est bien catherine barma du coeur
maintenant bruno solo laurent serait en
train d'abuser d'hélène ségara dans la
dans le carré vieille mais on le
comprend les bonnes hélène qui dit que
c'est pas elle qui abuse de nous fais
gaffe mais je sais mais sinon copines ou
dont copie nous optons jama pas me faire
prêtre copines où
il n y a trop de gens qui t'aiment
donc le film qui vous amène cher de
judith godrèche est une comédie de tonie
marshall avec karin viard françois
cluzet micheline presle nathalie baye
hélène fillières bernard menez qui
s'appelle france boutique alors
l'histoire se pressent d'affection mais
voilà alors c'est l'histoire d'un couple
composé de karin viard et de françois
cluzet qui ont créé une entreprise de
télé achat qui s'appelle france
boutiques dont ils sont les
présentateurs vedettes mais france
boutique accuse un petit tassement des
ventes ça va un petit peu moins bien et
il trouve une partenaire une société de
vente sur internet qui est dirigée par
nathalie baye qui veut les faire chuter
pour récupérer le temps d'antenne voilà
voilà l'intrigué alors c'est un univers
très très cheap qui est assez bien assez
bien décrit les personnages sont assez
bien construit s'éclipser et vous
idéalisez et vous judith vous êtes
présentatrice de tamis de la patronne
karin viard espèce de bimbo peroxydée
mais pas con non naïve c'est à dire que
pour elle le téléachat c'est une fin en
soi c'est vraiment elle pense qu'on peut
aller toujours plus haut alors que
présentatrice vedette avec karine et
françois mayle pense qu'on peut aller
encore plus haut c'est à dire qu'au
dessus je sais pas vraiment ce qu'il y a
et tu vas à l'avancé un mât c'est un
tremplin quoi et elle est ravie d'être
là comme avant elle faisait du porno bon
ben c'est mieux ça mieux c'est plus
reposant g a changé quoi dans votre vie
de devenir blonde platine judith je
pensais que ça allait changer beaucoup
de choses on m'avait dit justement que
les voitures allaient s'arrêter que je
pourrai traverser au feu vert etc et
c'est vrai que les premiers jours on a
le sentiment qu'il se passe quelque
chose en fait non je crois pas ces
différences dans la façon de s'habiller
si tu mets une jupe un peu courte et que
tu es blonde c'est là c'est la teuf
vraiment et toul est cité brune ça passe
mieux je vais rester blonde comme ça mon
prochain film on souhaite nous on essaye
ça y est c'est donc oui mais je le reste
reste la même coup la bombe d'un rôdeur
oui c'est obligé de tous nous tuer celle
qui m'en parlent elle m'a vu mon koala
elle te parle de ses poils pubiens
takraw précisant que les violences
avaient plusieurs vergers pas d'être
prête à produite en sortir t'as pas
envie de jouer un rôle de route un jour
tu parles si variés tous
bonjour à tous alors fonce on récapitule
les points forts de notre ensemble papa
qu'est ce que tu peux faire mais mr
ce sont des boutons bijoux les
composants pour son immense clameur
france j'ai vu l'ensemble femmes forment
ya pas un peu de mou dans l'évent oui
oui je pourrais peut-être le présenter
un peu différemment tu sais un peu plus
comme ça et bien ce blond c'est plus
moderne ouais merci moi je la comprends
bien sofia à l'essai de nous faire muter
femme nue et si tu préfères logement et
que tu fasses
très juste une pénétration vite ici
maman tout le monde mais c'est aussi un
petit couteau pointu que je pourrais par
exemple planter dans le coeur de mon
amoureuse si celui ci n'est pas gentil
avec coupet pour moi la paire à te rends
compte que tu vas faire couler langouët
cette boîte et autant à moi qu'à toi
c'est bien la seule chose qui nous rend
temps comme un
important avertissement rap c'est pas
moderne fois et dernier du vin un peu de
métier un peu de soi même un peu de
métier
suite à nos portes du neuf ce carré
magique est un carré à décongeler
derrière l'a fait c'est un endroit où je
croyais ne pas avoir la moindre lichette
de cellulite et bien portant et si nous
aimons être élégante enfin deux femmes
nous aimons aussi l'enlever pour pouvoir
nous montrer sous un autre jour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons passé quelques minutes pour
réfléchir
et notre morceau de cabillaud presque
totalement décongelé
france boutique de tonie marshall avec
karin viard françois cusey et judith
godrèche et notre invité ce soir avec
plaisir alors quand on voit le film et
quand on voit votre performance dans ce
film sérieusement on a du mal à croire
qu'à la même époque vous étiez en train
de vous séparer de dany boon non mais je
crois que les êtres humains ont une
capacité ont une force vitale qui fait
qu'ils peuvent vivre des choses assez
difficile et en même temps sublime et
justement la réalité et à travers notre
métier on arrive à échapper à la réalité
et justement le fait de faire une
comédie et d'être entouré par des gens
fin tony a été très proche de moi m'a
beaucoup aidé pendant pendant ces
moments là et une séparation c'est
toujours difficile mais c'est vrai que
quand on voit le générique de début et
de fin du film il ya des scènes d'un pro
et quand je vois ça je me dis mais
comment j'ai pu faire de l'impro vous à
vous avez une force incroyable on a tout
ça qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec daniel
c'était un petit côté voici gala annoncé
c'est noté tout est noté qu'ils allaient
me demande de relance
habibou responsable assure dany boon qui
va moi personnellement je m'en tape un
peu tout ça mais qu'est ce qui s'est
passé comme dans toutes les histoires
d'amour on peut rester des années
ensemble et puis on peut ne pas rester
des années ensemble c'est bien que non
la réponse que j'ai formé de la tyrie il
m'a dit c'est pas suffisant on est venu
là la fac je suis venu il m'a parlé de
ça et tout donc j'ai jamais les mains
comme ça dans le dos et je me
rendais pas compte puisque j'étais en
train de parler tu vas je me rendais pas
compte de ce qui se passait et pendant
ce temps il y avait un cameraman qui
filme et mes doigts et donc tout le
monde m'a dit était géniale château
c'est j'espère que c'est pas pour tout
le monde pareil
[Rires]
bien non mais moi je faisais ça un peu
dans le dos au choix c'est ça ou
bien alors j'ai dit concentré vous un
petit peu bon voilà et voilà non je
crois qu'avec dany en vain c'est là ce
qui les a pour l'heure reçu la semaine
dernière est ce que les ados oui ah bon
il fait fogiel r 10 ans j'étais dernier
la chanteuse ou par une part d'entre
eux estelle le personnage de de france
en titre dany la chanteuse
des moindres - les gens ils vont croire
que c'est monté
non ce qui les a tués avec ghani je peux
te le dire maintenant c'est la
médiatisation quand on faisait l'amour
sous les caméras bas c'était gênant pour
pour tout le monde je n'ai mas meilleur
chrono ça les a pas dérangé enfin ils
sont plus ensemble
c'est chiant mais qui a tout le temps à
vous êtes mais c'est un choix j'ai rien
à dire je suis
tu pourrais vivre avec un mec comme lui
comme outils dont elle a déjà donné dans
les comics
bien alors est elle le personnage de
france boutique est très arriviste
puisqu'on l'a dit elle veut passer du du
porno au téléachat et elle est beaucoup
plus arriver ce que vous parce que vous
quand vous parlez de votre carrière vous
dit judith godrèche et j'ai fait dans ma
carrière tout ce qu'il ne fallait pas
faire j'ai sacrifié ma
carrière à des mecs je suis pas parti
faire des films états unis parce que mon
mec avait dû du du boulot en france où
après j'ai fait un enfant enfin
utilement vous n'êtes pas très arriviste
c'est vrai non je suis pas du tout
arriver c'est à dire que j'ai jamais
sujet j'arrive pas à penser à al ala au
travail en termes de carrière je viens
un peu au jour le jour et en fonction de
ce que je ressens aide et de mes
sentiments voilà donc si c'est vrai que
kankan
j'étais très amoureuse et je n'avais pas
envie de
quitter partir d'être loin de la
personne avec qui j'étais je ne me
sentais pas le courage d'assumer en fait
mes propres désirs ou en tout cas mon
travail c'est pourtant une passion mais
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose sur
lequel
j'essaie de m'améliorer de ce côté là
pour arriver à me réalisés entendre pas
un bon tant qu'actrice en tant que
maîtresse est-ce que vous est ce que
vous pensez vous avez sacrifié un petit
peu votre carrière sur l'autel de
l'amour ma personne au moment où on
décide de le faire c'est pas un
sacrifice c'est une décision à l'adulte
voilà vous êtes quand même victime de ce
qu'on appelle l'amour fusionnel c'est à
dire cette idée de tout ramener à une
seule personne c'est à dire quand tu ne
vit qu'à travers l'autre mais je pense
qu'en fait c'est un truc assez féminin
et les femmes ont tendance un peu à se
mettre au second plan quand elle est
amoureuse je me sais pas bien là
avantage de
rêves de te demander le truc c'est que
j'ai pas les muscles du dos trêve je
suis pas très développée au niveau du
dos sans s'enflammer
non mais si vous avez un côté infirmière
doit coûter infirmières quoi c'est ça tu
regardes du bonheur missionnaire de
labour non mais c'est vrai mais toujours
en mission devra pour aider les jambes
c'est magnifique et si un jour vous
tombiez sur un mec qu'a pas besoin qu'on
l'aide un match ça m'aiderait beaucoup
en
penseriez avoue jour là ouais
bien
c'est fini là votre deuil là parce que
vous dites quand on se sépare de
quelqu'un une tête d'ail que tout à fait
bien sûr ça très bien c'est fini votre
deuil là je vais décoder il veut savoir
si tu avais
s'est passé alors j'ai passé cinq ans à
avoir j'ai pas dit ça non simplement lui
c'est fini magnéto
mais l'arrière deux blondes de pessah
pâques en main mais je lui dit tu
reviens quand tu veux ça me fait plaisir
j'espère se termina ses soirées télé en
pyjama avec les avec les chaussettes
et tout ça là avec mais ce qu'il faut
aimer en moi c'est le côté
transformation c'est à dire un soir ça
peut être le grand jeu
est ce que je dis la guêpière oui
asseoir l'auberge espagnole oui et le
lendemain mamie judith way et quelques
shows 16h à un séquel soir c'est les
soirs
voilà sinon elle va au supermarché non
il ya des trucs des briques des planons
chez judith godrèche shania les soirées
télé avec le pyjama des grosses
chaussettes il ya le caddies au
supermarché voilà quoi
et alors ce qui est incroyable
alors là vraiment je ne m'en doutais pas
une seconde mais c'est en préparant
cette interview comme quoi on ne connaît
pas encore très très bien c'est cette
angoisse que vous avez de la mort judic
c'est fou ça comment ça se fait ah je
sais pas mais je refoule complètement
les malgré tout vos psychanalyse il
sauve c'est pas arrivé en terre d'aude
sic analyse schéma aux gens comment ces
lacs sérieux je vais pas arriver à vous
débarrasser de de sa non non non non non
non non c'est un truc mais c'est même
pas que je n'accepte pas c'est que je ne
veux même pas y penser
parce que vous avez déclaré mon
testament est prêt et se dire c'est
vraiment un oui mais sa responsabilité
vis-à-vis du petit cheval et des chiens
mais sans les connaître ma mère aime pas
trop les chiens bon ben moi je les
prendrais vosgien si c'est vrai oui il
est toujours sincèrement ces chiens et
ses trois chats assez simple s'il lui
arrive rien des bras sa chatte com
bien
bien alors donc pour essayer de lutter
contre cette peur cette angoisse de la
mort jeudi de la brèche on va y arriver
vous allez voir on va faire une
interview jugement dernier
[Musique]
j'ai vu des brèches as tu joue au
docteur avec tes copains à l'école
oui
à l'époque
as-tu péché par penser aux par action
ouais j'ai volé des bonbons ah mais
c'est tout un joueur a doctor
as-tu pêcher à la mouche à la mouche à
la moux hammouche
mouche
non au oui non l'asticot je crois à
thierry tu as tes chances
judith godrèche as tu déjà convoité
l'homme d'autrui ouais et hualan jamais
c'est vrai l'homme d'autrui jamais
as-tu déjà commis le péché d'adultère
non
[Musique]
si enfin quand j'avais 13 ans devant lui
c'était un garçon s'appelle crise tant
que tu connais que tu connais bien car
même si cet été avec lui mais je suis à
13 ans
marina mon cul c'est pas
du coucher pas à 13 ans
16 ans non non et mais non non il y
avait un autre gars sont un peu vrai
mais j'ai juste fait un smatch croit
gilles godrèche as tu déjà commis l'acte
de chair sans volonté reproductrices
oui tu déjà penser à un juppé de manière
sexuelle
n'ont par contre quand j'étais petit je
faisais un rêve jacques martin ne
poursuivaient dans la forêt avec une
piqûre
judith a su profiter de sa notoriété
pour draguer des garçons non le dernier
ep les garçons qu'il faut si tu fais
semblant d'être occupés pour ne pas
donner d'argent un sdf non moi je sais
pas simuler en fait oh c'est parce que
à l'époque
as tu essayé pour échapper aux paparazzi
de te cacher derrière les oreilles de
dany boon
[Musique]
la boutique heures
j'ai un cadeau pour vous qui s'est passé
très très bon c'est un petit cadeau
qu'on vous a préparé suis dit avec la
production mais c'est moisi attend c'est
super bon et maintenant
voilà
m
[Applaudissements]
papa
voici bruno solo yvan le bolloc'h
[Musique]
bonsoir
bonsoir comment ça va
ouais mais bon soir les amis bonsoir les
amis qui est bataille qu'est fontaine 1
bien alors caméra café en fer force
boutique on va faire le télé-achat alors
d'abord il ya caméra café la deuxième
saison l'intégrale en coffret 6 dvd dont
deux dvd de bonus ben voilà regardé
c'était sait pas compter les séries avec
la sec mais c'est pareil il marche bien
à l'âme avis bob rae
c'est l'optimisation de tout ce qu'on a
fait pendant deux ans à savoir que
maintenant caméra café c'est une
entreprise bien huilé on a arrêté la
production ça continue il ya des inédits
jusqu'en juin 2004 la télévision mais on
était arrivé à une telle osmose entre
les comédiens la troupe en fait qu'on
avait réussi à créer et les auteurs que
effectivement maintenant il ya une
qualité assez régulière ce qui remet un
café ça se résume assez bien dans cette
intégrale et les bonus en poche c'est
pour faire plaisir c'est notamment tous
les caméra café les adaptations à
l'étranger et l'italie la grèce
voilà tous les pays qui ont acheté une
dizaine de pays qu'on m'a dit tu ne sais
quoi caméra cappuccino c'est ça mon
chez-moi
chine ces caméras de surveillance en mer
et en irak c'est bagdad café voilà bravo
bon est ce que est ce qu'il le vende
bien là parce que tu sais que judith
vient de faire un film s'appelle france
boutique où elle est animatrice de télé
achat qu'est ce que vous croyez sauf
qu'il s'est passé exprimé avec les mains
il se tient pas à ses droits ils
sourient pas assez et il parle pas des
points forts mais ça peut paraître
prétentieux mais on n'a même plus besoin
de le vendre ça se vend tout seul
bien bien là sur les 100 sketch qu'on
tourne à peu près par abe par saison là
il y en a une quarantaine qui sont la
quintessence même la substantifique
moelle de l'humour des caméra café à mal
nos france boutique donc sans le 29
alors on continue caméra café puisque à
pâques le kappa qui les dvd en bd ouais
ça s'appelle tu en veux tu en veux
voilà tu en auras poitiers deux frères
jumeaux venait tout est dit j'estime
année un troisième dessinateur il dit il
écrivait dessinent ensemble et c'est à
l'issue de la projection de caméra café
en belgique parce que c'est aussi
exploité en belgique qu'ils ont décidé
nous ont contactés nous aujourd'hui on
aimerait faire une bd autour d'eux des
personnages caméra café voilà et c'est
donc une initiative et ça nous a plu ils
nous ont montré et les croquis on les
trouve plutôt bien répondu
oui c'est vrai ouais ils t'ont pas mis
assez de trader vendeur ça et là ça va
partir
mais bon ils ont pas mis assez très
c'est à dire non mais tu vois ton visage
est trop il allait cesser le principe
d'une caricature cette annexion oui les
buriné mon camarade romain n'a pas un
gros nez comme ça mais gros nez n'a
jamais déflorer joli visage à
[Musique]
voilà qui à bientôt il y aura les nuits
caméra café sur le modèle des nuit du
zapping en fait ce qu'on essaye de faire
c'est de faire un label de caméra café
parce que c'est pas tous les jours qu'on
fait des choses qui fonctionnent à la
télévision etc ont du succès par exemple
effectivement tant qu'à nettoyer autant
faire briller donc on va en profiter ça
soit arrivé
là à vous en profitez donc effectivement
il ya la bande dessinée il ya le film
qu'on est en train de finir d'écrire
avec nos meilleurs auteurs et puis
bientôt il y aura un disque c'est à dire
le disque on voudrait profiter de notre
petite notoriété pour aider des
collègues annuler sa faim longtemps un
bon moment qu'on traîne dans la musique
et on s'aperçoit qu'il ya plein de mecs
qui sont très talentueux mais qui soirée
qui sont soit trop vieux pour passer à
star académie soit trop grosse ou arabe
soit pour rentrer dans les critères donc
on va essayer de leur donneur chance 90
qu'un discours donne la chance à des
groupes qui n'ont pas eu la chance de
signer justement et on va faire
découvrir au travers le label caméra
café qu'est ce que tu fais là toi je
vais vite un nom donné tu tiens je dit
je pense à toi tu vois c'est un
pèlerinage annuel c'est-à-dire yates a
pas c'est pas derrière ces moisi tonton
cadeau vous êtes des salles où
un problème elles ont dû rester mon père
c'est vrai je vous l'assuré la regarder
non non non c'est bon
pour l'heure des cadeaux gens comme vous
donc je voulais vous gâter ses membres
le goûter tout ça ensemble et je fais
des fleurs maintenant quand tu le sens
faut que ça gêne bicoeur faut que ce
soit un joli moment de télé il faut
qu'ils aient un truc qui se passe entre
vous
peut-être pas mais voilà attend
maintenant tu gères c'est toi qui gère
ces tombes ok tu me dire tu as acheté
avec ton argent le sétois je sais donc
il va y avoir tout plein de choses
caméra café des cravates des ajustements
on essaie de ne pas être trop cynique
par rapport à ça c'est palais c'est pas
tout pour notre pomme ou quoi ouais gros
distribuer une partie de l'argent qu'on
gagne souvent à des affamés mais c'est
vrai les droits de droit a été donnée à
droite
largage de neige parce que voilà et un
personnage on fera pareil aussi pour la
une partie de la bd pour le disque aussi
on va faire des fonds de soutien pour
des pour des jeunes auteurs qu'est ce
que la branche maintenant j'ai dit elle
ne marche alors comme ça
alors
regarde trop de films pornos toi je t'ai
pas vu dans notre habitat france
boutiques en france boutis j'essaie d'en
revenir à mon film un petit peu
tendu on s'est fait de manière très
fort m'a dit c'est à dose homéopathique
on est à raison mais fais ta promo ma
chérie tu sais ça j'essaie de faire ma
promo mais c'est pas évident non plus
verser
la pâte interrompre ait de conneries
bien alors bruno vous aider à assurer la
direction d'acteurs d'une d'une série de
fictions courtes pour france 2 qui
commence lundi qui va remplacer un gars
une fille qui s'appelle domicile adoré
qui est produit avec la même équipe qu'à
caméra canon cac alain kappauf eh ouais
ma pomme ouais voilà le pitch c'est un
compositeur défunt qui observent avec
humour le quotidien de sa famille
recomposée depuis depuis l'au delà je
suis les limbes voilà une belle idée bah
oui on pense que c'est une bonne idée et
la voilà on attendait une vingtaine
d'épisodes cédé 6 minutes c'est
effectivement sur le même format un
petit peu caméra café sauf que là c'est
plus académique quoi il ya des champs
contre champs c'est filmé comme une
série quoi mais vu par le prisme d'un
esprit qui observe donc c'est un
personnes et de familles personne ne le
voit personne ne peut pas intervenu dans
la réalité il ne fait que commenter ce
qu'il est ce qu'il voit et là donc on
fait en a fait une trentaine l'épisode
on enceinte on est en train de trouver
le rythme qu'on avait dans caméra café
justement et essayer de trouver cette
même dynamique et d'écriture et de jeu
là pour l'instant il ya des sketches qui
sont formidablement dans cet esprit là
il y en a qui sont un petit peu plus
dans le tâtonnement mais je pense que à
très court terme on va créer cette même
troupe qu'on avait fait sans caméra café
chouette quoi ouais mais bon faut dire
que c'est bien de réhabiliter
d'expression chouette ouais et c'est un
mot qui va revenir on avoir peur et j'en
ai donc comme ça j'ai pris des chouettes
et ben il est chouette avec nous même si
c'est un peu dépassé mon côté un peu
puéril ça va être chouette j'aime bien
c'est bien sauf s'il bat s'ébattent ses
100 saas voilà c'était pas tant épatant
s'effeuillera gisti
ça c'était en france beauté à oui marie
peuple ne soit jamais se ralentit a
commenté ici parler
tu sais tu chantais way
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious
toute ma vie j'ai bien été absents
esprits maintenant que je ne suis plus
là j'ai décidé de ne plus quitter maison
ferait les yeux doux
missionné pour mais excuse moi la maison
des sancerre pas bien la pente alors au
5e et balayer la maison a dit jean
nombre des sages oui c'est alice au pays
des merveilles comme cendrillon moi je
suis
véhicules courant d'un tour
son
domicile adoré la première fiction qui
est de l'esprit
voilà à domicile had aurait servi à
19h50 gens pensent de nombreux fans à
tous les jours tous les jours tous les
jours la chaîne nous a donné combien de
temps pour que s'installe 50 numéros 50
numéros notamment parce que france 2 et
m6 sont qu'on produit france boutique
ouais ouais enfin le coup de franges du
côté de bonal loi je me sens pendant le
no 1 c'est chouette cette promo mais
c'est sans doute et beauvais s'est
même inscrit de l'attaché de presse que
dans la loge temps je voudrais vous
inscrire à
droite catherine
oh
obama m l'outil en main
[Musique]
voilà messieurs je joue maintenant à
temps long je voudrais que nos amis
téléspectateurs jamais les attacher
comprennent comprennent comment ça se
passe du livre godrèche et là évidemment
il une attachée de presse avec elle qui
l'accompagnent qui s'occupe d'elle
jusqu'à est bien maquillé ce qu'elle est
heureuse et c'est là s'est attaché de
presse est là pour veiller à ce que la
promotion du film soit bien fait et
quand on travaille pour professionnels
minutes cigale on a intérêt à assurer
alors astrid bonsoir alors un street est
ce que vous pensez que la promotion de
france boutique a été bien fait très
concrètement oui pas ainsi donc qu'est
ce qu'on pourrait dire de plus sur la
liste est très très coupé pendant cet
intervalle
qu'est-ce que mais parce que laurent lui
a dit alors si c'est ça les missions
très bien ça mais je veux qu'on appelle
stéphane cette musique
[Musique]
j'ai mon pote tu aurais pu être notées
ici ouais c'est le monde alain kappauf
alors
à
cédric de caméra café il n'y aura pas
ils jouent mal de
jeux termine avec un strip ma petite
astrid très bonnes attaches est passé
d'attaché salle de la vérité si je mens
numéros 1 étoile a souvent les stations
donc voilà je sais qu'on me dit que
laurent lui a pourri sa promo c'est je
suis d'accord d'accord commencé d'être
l'assistant de laurent baffie ces casses
couilles quand même non
ça des gens honnêtes soient négligés
aulas répond je te donne une carte de
bondi
et on va voir si ça marche
pas c'est comme si mon assistant je vais
lui intimer l'ordre de revenir il est
bloqué au passage on verra si c'est de
la merde s'écarte d'accord ça serait
bien elle va bouger qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire de plus à dany tu te reposes
oui la droite parti avait pas moins que
tu es déjà partie d un hologramme
merci monsieur
la brasserie
[Musique]
suite
yp
[Musique]
et maintenant j'ai accueil et même ses
bras
[Musique]
bonsoir et n bon qu'est ce qui se passe
alors comme je sais qu'on peut couper au
montage je viens ici je veux montrer mes
seins
qu'est ce que papa je voudrais dire que
vous allez faire vachement de peine à ma
mémé avec ça parce que c'est fait maison
et que si un joueur n'est pas hermétique
on peut pas le savoir ce qui est fait
maison c'est toujours meilleur un cadeau
ça devient une private joke ça devient
nude va faire du joint samaté nos frères
des joints de mai mais ça va être
incroyable
compris la grand mère d'hélène ségara
des joints qui son père métis et donc
c'est sympathique c'est dur à vivre au
quotidien
via l'antenne que c'était un cadeau de
toile elle va le reconnaître c'est son
prénom elle va connaître son projet bien
naturel qu'elle est centrée non
ça que j'ai demandé à m est à droite
parce que j'ai une très bonne droite est
le prénom de sa grand mère je ne regarde
pas alors ça ne te regarde pas quel que
soit ton prénom c'est pas très grave ses
rillettes sont moisis mais j'en connais
doigts
[Rires]
c'est un cadeau que j'ai fait à judith
en lui faisant croire que c'était moi
qui allais coeur ça peut arriver mais
oui voilà c'est une petite affaire est
resté dix ans au dessus mais je voulais
vous dire on est le prénom de toi même
et tu me fais tu me fais chier je
t'adore malgré son handicap patronymique
je suis à 200 concerts avec toi ça à
tibou maxi beaucoup message pour savoir
quel est le prénom de la mère hélène et
narbonne message c'est pas correct c'est
à grandeur sans déconner mois sinon j'ai
eu ma petite mémé dans le sud-ouest qui
fait défaut gras délicieux sauf quand le
joint n'est pas
faire l'émission parce que les pauvres
ils attendent de toute la soirée on peut
le manger se trouve donc bien sûr son
nom
si la non mais si tu veux chez park
oui le podium je sais pas vous mais nous
les vidéos pauline mais ça n'a juste pas
le mec qui t'offre un grand pinard et
manque de pot il a bouchonné on sait
comme ces fleurs lâchant des crèches
suppose des jeunes étaient sur un banc
de thons rouges est fort chez magasin je
suis très gêné parce que je savais pas
que
comme d'habitude
rien bravo hathaway battue c'est quelque
chose
qui fait d'ailleurs ce dernier qui fait
la vie impossible à combler l'écart et
parce qu'on sait tous les cas d'homme
d'état n'a jamais eu des champignons
bien sûr c'est la vie ça arrive
alors catherine c'est ce qu'elle m'a dit
4 1 elle m'a dit je veux plus voir ce
pot par les gendarmes a fait qu elle n y
paraît il ya quatre ans
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'avais bien pour les gens qu'ils
connaissent leur histoire
bien oui et les s'égarant soit 34 ans
dans malienne
j'ai même
elle est aussi allée l'a dit mais tu
restes en dix ans hélène ségara le
mariage vous réussit ce mariage c'est
passé le 30 août 2003 vous avez épousé
mathieu mathieu lecat 14 ans rappelons
le
père de votre second fils mathéo vous
êtes
voilà je savais qu'on avait parlé de mon
mari j'attends mon bébé orlando et mon
bouquin ou mon passé après on aura fait
le tour bah oui mais je savais que les
dires c'est j'ai moi même à prévoir que
j'ai perdu je suis quand même dommage
dommage et bien non mais c'est normal
qu'on parle de ça est ce que c'est quand
même bien c'est moi je suis désolé mais
c'est une très belle histoire vous vous
êtes rencontrés en 2001 chez maxim's
lors de la remise de votre premier
disque de diamant hélène ségara et puis
ensuite il ya eu deux ans de grand amour
et vous avez dit très souvent que la
différence d'âge n'était pas un problème
pour 25 ans d'écart c'est pas mon se
revoie pas exagérer je me sens pas être
sa grand-mère où je ne m'attarde pas tu
sais j'ai deux enfants j'ai ce qu'il
faut pour faire ça maintenant ce qui est
certain c'est que tout le monde a parlé
de ce mariage moi je compte pas vivre ma
vie cachée j'aime quelqu'un maintenant
ce qui est certain c'est qu'évidemment
vu que certains paparazzi avait loué
l'appartement qui en face de la
cathédrale on a vu du beau faire non
mais sérieusement on n'a pas fait de
faire part on appris de la sécu avait
six mecs et ils ont cassé les pieds vont
ils ont été limités agressif avec le
photographe de famille nous enfin tu
vois un moment donné quand toi tu
choisis de pavant de photos de ton
mariage quand tu choisi de garder un
événement intime pour toi parce que moi
j'avais envie de me marier à l'église
soit mais après ça fait la une de tous
les magazines les photos ont été vendus
revendu revendu revendus non moi ce qui
m'a beaucoup inquiété s'est créé saman
j'ai vu un article dans gala sur le fait
que les femmes prenaient des maris ou
des amants de fait le choix c'est vrai
s'il préfère les mecs plus jeunes mais
mais mais mais mais on a choisi un mec
de cinq ans vainqueur devant dieu ça
m'inquiète moi personnellement pendant
ma femme quand c'était la star c'est à
dire les mecs qui préfèrent janet on en
parle beaucoup moins j'ai senti ce truc
là en plus tu es plus grave et du pollen
sur le bled
ça c'est à pita personnes malades ici
grand mère d
envoi pas y'a pas à l'écran je vois que
je contrôle mais non tu as plein de
trucs et ses fleurs la crise et que
c'est qu'une telle élection peut dire
c'est au
nom de ce même avec d'entrée la nature
une femme
qu'on peut avancer un petit peu la
prochaine les gens ne pas exagérer
alors donc mariage ajaccio à 11 heures
la mairie à 15 heures en la cathédrale
orlando témoin
non mais tu vois tu litres ou une
mauvaise presse parce qu'ils ont dit
n'importe quoi julie zenatti relandeau
témoins orlando m'accompagner à l'hôtel
mettez moi c'était mes amis d'enfance et
alors à l'hôtel ça a donné quoi c'est
bien
comme quoi la différence l'agencé les
conneries ça va mal au dos et puis tout
face à face en même temps est-ce qu'on
va y arriver donc orlando pas témoin
succédé sur le mariage ah bon il est à
patrick fiori si oui c'est ça ton ex
fiori bah non pas moi
et
oui mais c'est vrai chico
things are et je suis con par la sq et
moi hélène je suivais relancer le débat
jeune fille je ne sais quand j'étais
avec dernière ça et ça a duré pas très
très longtemps mais j'ai quand même reçu
des lettres de menaces parce que j'étais
une femme qui détournait un jeune homme
de son droit chemin un jour de dire
quand même que le père de mon premier
enfant à 20 ans de plus que moi et que
je me spécialise pas dans la chair
fraîche l'amour c'est l'amour et on
regarde pas en demande pas une carte
d'identité et basta quoi
la vertu aussi au mariage oui c'est un
ami à toi tu veux c'est un ami à moi
c'est bizarre quand même tes amis tous
arthur orlando tout ça ça c'est pas amis
excuse moi mais moi j'ai pas fou qu il
est pas venue en mai puis on sai non
nathan excuse moi j'ai après tu pleures
parce que c'est médiatisé il ya
peut-être quelque chose on va parler on
peut aborder des mains de mes meilleurs
amis qui viennent du sud on n'en parle
pas parce que personne ne connaît pas
avec des gens médiatisé alors oui avec
garou parce que je les aime profondément
oui avait arthur parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui même s'il ne fait pas que
des choses que je cautionne et je suis
d'accord avec toi sur certaines choses
il a un grand coeur et je le défendrai
adore ça excuse moi il ya trop de gens
qui t'aiment belem est ce qu est ce qui
là est ce qu'il a donné de l'argent la
quête arthur on
si les mariages et un enterrement le
jour d'un mariage tu crois que tu veux
regarder qui fait la quête et tu n'en
avais pas voilà tu t'es envier c'est
habillée comme en gt habillé en blanc
avec une grande belle robe une robe un
peu plus simple pour l'amérique après
l'assaut de rillettes c'est émouvant
comment tu arrêtes et et rillettes
premier puisque c'est du flan d'abord la
regrettée défunte est un foie gras au
début j'ai potassé ça peut arriver non
mais tu peux dire c'est qu'il a
un jeu un père meetic ça m'est arrivé
non on va peut-être pas faire l'émission
tout le monde en annonçant sa non
maintenant on voudrait parler des
fiançailles à savoir ce que les futures
ont fait
j'adore ce matin si tu sais pourquoi je
suis comme ça c'est parce que tu m'as
pas invité mais je fais rien n'est pas
assez intime je suis désolé tiens ça tu
l'as bien pris dans la gueule qui sera
invité au prochain tour
car j'ai perdu leur divorce donc je
t'aime beaucoup mais on sait ans
apprécie quand on se croise je pense
qu'on toujours honteux précis quand on
te croit soir mais n'est que reste un
peu là-bas ça retombe toi non mais tu
sais il vend il a soulevé un truc très
intéressant et 2 et il a parlé des
pipoles de mon mariage je dis alors
parce que j'ai des amis dans ce métier
je vois pas les invités parce qu'ils
sont people maintenant non c'est pas ça
c'est qu'après si on s'étonne on s'est
pris un petit peu quand même non mais si
on s'étonne après qu'il y ait des si tu
es invité madame michu ta grand mère
tanya
des paparazzis alors qu'à partir du
moment où tu dis qu'ils ardisson qui va
venir mais pour me faire pardonner pas
avoir invité jeter amener un petit
cadeau même le moisi tu vas adorer
est-ce que vos cadets aux parents très
ciblée
[Musique]
doc gynéco je trouve que cette émission
elle manque de mascotte maintenant
tandja cadeau pour toi regarde
cette émission c'est une astuce à passer
pour le bain c'est qu'elle est maman ce
qui l'amusé mon ventre mais bon c'est un
bas mais pourquoi bah oui
oui ben je me suis rabattu donc ça va
démarrer maintenant
le marché n'a pas de droite
franchement on s'emmêle dans les
émissions de tv et henrik abel est vite
donné même au sénat
ces gars on vous souhaite autant de
succès en amour que dans le métier vous
êtes là la success story de la variété
française de ces dernières années est
régulièrement c'est vrai régulièrement
désignée comme la chanteuse préférée des
français vous le savez ça quand même
c'est très très gentil mais je pense que
ça c'est lui tutu c'est l'amour ça va ça
vient quoi mais oui oui encore une
chanson
alors oui même votre dernier album s'est
déjà vendu à 500 mille exemplaires au
nom d'une femme le précédent à 2
millions d'exemplaires
vous êtes la meilleure vendeuse
française je sais pas à moi je vous dis
bah écoutez je sais pas me vendre à
fabio deux bords tu rigoles maintenant à
fabian elle est là j'aime pas parce que
moi ça veut dire que c'est un marathon
là moi j'suis pas de marathon avec
personne et en plus de ça je fais pas de
marathon avec moi même c'est à dire tu
as vendu des millions il faut que tu
fasses tes passes et devenir non non non
non non la sentence en occupent s'ils
fonctionnent sept chiffres c'est une
artiste voulu la paix elle sait pas si
elle vend elle elle est créée non je
suis contente je suis content tu sais
écoute moi oui je sais pas si tu as vécu
dans quinze mètres carrés dans ta vie
moi oui avec mon fils et j'ai vraiment
galéré suffisamment pour être contente
et apprécier ce qui m'arrive vraiment
aujourd'hui mais vous avez raison
hellène moi je suis sûr qu'elle a raison
oui mais elle est sensée qui vient de 15
mètres carrés et était a été carrée
humaine donc votre dernier album est
sorti au printemps dernier hélène ségara
album écrit en collaboration avec maxime
le forestier lionel florence patrick
juvet un album avec beaucoup de chansons
d'amour mais aussi beaucoup de chansons
engagées
beaucoup nous martèle une chanson par
exemple sur la pédophilie vous êtes
contre oui c'est sûr ça totalement
contre une chanson sur les enfants
soldats vous êtes contre soi qu'on peut
le dire mais qui n'est pas content
sourit comme le disent à part les
personnes malades et dérangé qui ont des
enfants comme ça mais qui n'est pas
contre voilà bien alors cette loi aura
pas au signé avec qui mais chanter cette
chanson c'est celle qu'a fait la
solitudine vous connaissez cette chanson
vous pouvez alors maintenant on va faire
un truc personne voilà vous met à
chanter je les adore allez-y mais je
connais pas l'état non mais c'est pas
grave juste un peuple à la solitudine
frein à main dans les postes voilà c'est
ça c'est ça donne est possibile et 10 bd
la vie à seize lots et non non non non
non non mon ami mon nom c'est la seule
qui dit la lafa aussi
alors maintenant maintenant il ya une
tournée en france et l'olympia du 3 au 8
novembre est ce que vous êtes prête nom
ça faire plaisir en nombre est prête oui
mais on n'est jamais prêt quel est le
prénom de ta grand mère je voudrais lui
faire un bisou non je veux pas des
bisous de toi madrid puisse internautes
de grand mère je suis sûr qu'un mode
horde à grand mère je parle en son nom
je suis sûr qu'à madame dubé mais
mes mouly c'est titi mai moulées sur la
batellerie iata
le pâté et bien je l'appelle et céline
alors début novembre par et le livre de
didier le cas journaliste père de votre
mari mathieu lecat le livre s'appelle en
aparté et vous raconter hélène ségara
dans ce livre votre vie ouais bah si
quand même une partie vous racontez
votre naissance par accident ça tu te
finir mais non j'ai pris un niveau très
vieux le truc qu'il était il est comme
ça t'as pas vu je suis parti en arrière
si ces moments de panique ou du temps
partir là tout ce que je sais c'est
comme ça il parle comme un vieux ces
bons ne pas dire que vous êtes sympas
jérôme pineau rachetant merde je suis
sur tout ce qui se dit de juin vous
permettez au 15 mai 2010 et qu'il est en
équilibre précaire choix dans lequel m
segarra dans ce livre qui s'appelle un
aparté vous raconter votre vie votre
naissance par accident alors que vos
parents ne rien comprendre que c'est
n'importe quoi vous renoncé
non mais là j'écoute par contre j'ai
fait tellement me sens donc c'est le
moment où elles n'étaient simplement
attends tu es tu a suspendu elle n'est
pas attendue c'est ça qui sous tend ces
ses parents ne s'entendent déjà plus en
mer mais merde t'es pas que parler du
bonheur non si c'est moi je vous dis
tout de suite si c'est pour faire des
plans comme ça sur la vie d'hélène
ségara moi j'en parle pas du bouquin
maintenant même
je connais bulli depuis dix ans il n'a
jamais fait ça on peut lui accorder
c'est la première c'est la dernière bon
alors donc dans ce livre vous raconte
hélène ségara votre naissance par
accident alors que vos parents ne
s'entendent déjà plus leur divorce huit
ans plus tard votre beau-père
pieds-noirs macho c'est pas le mot mais
plus jeune que votre mère oui ça aurait
dû vous mettre la puce à l'oreille ça
ben non moi justement le je pense que
c'est pas une question d'âge d'aimer les
enfants des autres ou pas d'accord c'est
lui ce cet homme qui vous est un petit
peu voler votre enfance enfants tous les
cases qui ce qu'il en restait et il est
sans doute à l'origine de la méfiance
que vous avez envers les hommes hélène
ségara là disons qui m'a appris à me
battre très jeune et ça peut être qu'il
faut que j'en remercie même s'il est
plus là mais en tout cas oui m'a rendu
très méfiante et il m'a fait grandir
très vite mais je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui vivent une histoire
comme ça maintenant la meilleure manière
de dépasser tout ça c'est de s'en sortir
et de fond c'est quand même voilà vous
raconter dans steam hélène ségara votre
départ de la maison et vos retrouvailles
avec votre mère beaucoup plus tard quand
vous êtes enceinte elle revient vers
vous vous racontez vos débuts dans la
chanson les piano-bars nous endroit un
peu louche un petit peu mal famés dans
lesquelles disent on est 15 est obligé
de chanter dans la région de hyères
plein de plus passé d'où le nom non non
non mais ça je veux dire je renie pas du
tout c'est une très bonne école et à
paris j'ai même travaillé dans un dans
un bar où il y avait des prostituées je
les respecte beaucoup parce qu'elles
m'ont énormément tgs mais je te dirai
près voilà il ya un scoop dans le
bouquin c'est en fait que pendant les
années 80 hélène ségara devient look
destroy vous étiez fans de depeche mode
mais vous savez que david gahan le
leader de depeche mode et là ce soir il
va arriver quand on lui a dit que
j'étais là il dit je viens
bien celle-là bouleversé longtemps que
j'ai pu au téléphone qui va bien devenir
david gamme de ses fans de kurdes
d'indochine est alors de metallica gjp
l'iphone
tu sais les gens ils sont une idée qui
cache et je me tiens pas eu envie de
faire cette musique nécessairement parce
que ça qu'il faudrait pas tester le
futur tu vas j'adore alanis morissette
c'est la plus proche de ce que
matt asti tueur vocale mais bon
sincèrement
j'étais tellement révoltée pendant cette
période là que j'allais vers tout ce qui
pouvait m'aider à faire sortir cette
révolte et puis dans l'école où j'étais
j'avais un prof de maths qui
m'autorisait à chanter en cours et ça je
crois pas que selon lui qu'un et mes
camarades me voyez vraiment comme
quelqu'un de super révolter et pas
forcément de très dur quoi quand je
chantais la douceur s'installer et là je
me faisais plein d'amis et ça m'a permis
d'être aimée des autres et pour moi ça a
été
elle habite finement le garde-à-vous là
plus personne par monsieur parce que
c'est émouvant c'est un vrai témoignage
qui avait et saluer les gens insensible
brèche à arrêter de parler de france
méconnu
charité daniel a tout arrêté donc à
chaque fois qu'il ya pu rien à dire je
crois que les gars je crois que s'ils
voulaient faire un petit break chez vous
allez prendre une bière à les points
d'un petit léon à moi quelque chose
comme ça faire l'amour oui j'ai envie de
mordre l'amour entre couper la télé
faire l'amour est alors ils ont tous
couper la rater
les majors il tracé direct à l'époque
vous étiez pas du tout féminine non
j'étais très garde son c'est marrant je
vois ce désir pas de flirt non non très
platonique fallait pas comme tripote
j'ai joué au football c'est boulogne et
ouais mais c'est officiel il fallait pas
construit par louis fallait pas me
chercher c'est vrai que j'étais trop mal
à battre avec la moitié des garçons de
mon école dans les douches et pessac
impressionné le plus
non mais c'était ça veut dire que ces
gens adorent tirer quand tu fais
bizarrement ça fait pas mal aussi ses
conséquences c'est un
attendait un seul homme jusqu'à l'âge de
23 ans et la rue après 23 hommes en non
non non non non alors d'autres questions
là dessus ben oui orlando
parlant de ça va bien qu'on soit bien
non landau orlando ça a été la rencontre
de ma vie c'est vrai est ce qu'il est et
qui joue orlando
de ma vie à mes yeux
je crois qu'il est exigeant mais il est
surtout professionnelle c'est à dire que
c'est quelqu'un qui
il a un tel recul sur ce métier je crois
que c'est un des derniers comme ça dans
ce métier il a il a une oreille il a une
oreille à oui il arrive ans j'arrive en
studio il sait si j'ai pleuré ici c'est
j'ai dormi c'est comment je suis dedans
j'ai rien à lui dire quoi c'est dommage
qu'ils soient pas là je le vaux bien
embrasser les rillettes la veille
oui arrêtons et bien savait difficile à
monter parce qu'on le dit tout les
dominer trident orlando et ils exigent
on avait un interview si orlando
l'exigent
[Musique]
alors pour rester la chanteuse française
numéro un hélène ségara si orlando
l'exigeait ce que vous seriez prête à
manger un pot de rillettes avariée nom
est ce que vous seriez prête à reprendre
6 kg non mais là il faut que je perde a
donc orlando et orlando pour lui savait
pas ce que c'était d'avoir une artiste
qui a une grosse presse donc quand j'ai
annoncé et séduira mondiale mais que tu
vas trop grosse j'ai dit non je vais
être enceinte et donc j'ai fait ma
grossesse comme toute femme et puis
quand j'ai accouché me dis moi
maintenant tu as encore très grosse donc
forcément j'ai dit alors par contre il
m'a sorti un truc très très joli c qui
m'a dit mais finalement qu'elle est
publique et même grosse la même enceinte
qui thème qu'est finalement si tu
pouvais rester enceinte jusqu'au mois
d'octobre à mai j'ai accouché aurait
donc à l'ancienne à l'ancienne
non mais lâche origines seulement parce
que ça m'agace légende pas compris que
je venais de mettre non plus toutes les
autres
allez
est ce que si orlando l'exigé même
ségara vous ferez gonfler encore plus
les normes et les xhosas il existe
d'abord il exigera jamais ça c'est pas
du tout branché bimbo sur l'endos
l'exigé ce que vous seriez prête à
chanter des chansons que vous ne
comprenez pas non non non tu me
demandera jamais ça mais tout si j'ai du
caractère il le sait voilà comme moi
j'essaie de temps en temps de lui dire
on peut pas en faire une petite un peu
plus rock'n'roll sur l'endos l'exigé ce
que vous seriez prête à voter françois
hollande aux prochaines élections
présidentielles
oui absolument qu'elles fonctionnent à
venir c'est le fun dit pas ça non pas
françois hollande mais de façon
c'est moi j'ai jamais c'est marrant
parce que la question je la pose
pratiquement toutes les semaines j'ai
jamais vu quelqu'un qui était prêt à
voter françois hollande ou ségolène
ségolène royal il est bon mais quand je
sers maintenant sérieusement comment ça
se fait que les gens ne veulent pas
voter françois hollande ils sont prêts à
voter fabius à mes amis c'est encore
pire à moi ainsi on a oublié l affaire
du sang contaminé gens qui sont prêts à
voter fabius plutôt que françois
hollande
tu sais je vais te dire un truc moi je
vais faire je vous laisse je vais
laisser les politiciens fait la
politique sincèrement il ya il ya des
gens de gauche que j'aime beaucoup
par exemple j'aime beaucoup de la
nourriture copains orlando il est proche
des gens et je trouve que
mais pas que pour ça non si j'échoue est
assez grande il ya des gens encore lent
douanes bien que j'aime pas michou
michou par exemple lancé mon père me
faisait mal de neige ou
encore fondu j'ai longtemps tout
moi j'adore me je te jure regardes et tu
crois que ces mêmes n'y a que le bleu
qui change tout tu changes le bleu c'est
les mêmes d'un mois
ça
m
interview
et maintenant alors voilà ça c'est un
truc pour vous maintenant là pour vous
de là vous étiez là le jour où thierry
meyssan est venu nous expliquer qu aucun
avion n'était tombé sur le pentagone
c'est bien toi notre scepticisme et des
interrogations et des questions qu'on
lui a posé et à dieu dieu sait à quel
point nous avions raison d'un manque de
préparation oratoire et green bay ce
soir on va vous proposer un nouveau cas
ivan et bruno c'est qui a vraiment tué
john fitzgerald kennedy voici william
reymond et billy soliste
m
[Musique]
et
bonsoir william reymond bonsoir billy
solstice donc que william reymond vous
êtes journaliste auteur notamment de
deux mini çi non coupable les assassins
retrouver le livre qui a servi de base
au téléfilm de tf1 et dans lequel vous
émettez l'hypothèse qu'en fait la
famille d'anglais la famille drummond
n'a pas été assassiné par gaston
dominici ou par l'un de ses enfants mais
par les services secrets voilà ça c'est
une thèse qui est très critiqué mais qui
a quand même séduit tf1 puisqu'ils ont
fait le thème de leurs deux téléfilms
exact cris critiquer mais très souvent
pour des raisons complètement fausses et
qui prouve encore une fois que les
journalistes télé lorsqu'ils font des
articles ne lis pas les enquêtes et on
m'a reproché des choses qui étaient en
téléfilm en pensant que je les avais
écris moi alors que ce n'est pas du tout
le cas voilà donc en tous les cas vous
avez été à l'honneur deux soirs de suite
sur tf1 est aujourd'hui votre thèse sera
sans doute aussi critiqué mais nous
avons là deux experts qui sont punis
solo et yvan le bolloc'h qui ont déjoué
thierry meyssan je crois la première
seconde et on a tout de suite cru que
c'était de la flûte voilà rapport à
messanges avait vu l'émission d'ailleurs
par rapport à mes sens je me suis
retrouvé souvent face à l'huile dans des
émissions comme des débats pour dire un
avion c'est bien écrasé sur le pentagone
j'habite aux états unis j'avais vécu ça
quasiment en direct est bon c'est
thierry meyssan moi je ne suis pas tiré
mais sans non j passage dit simplement
vous avez la chance d'avoir deux
observateurs qui sont habitués aux
populations voilà alors le bouquin
s'appelle jfk le dernier témoin c'est
publié chez flammarion alors sur la
bande rouge sur le livia marqué
assassinat de kennedy enfin la vérité 1
donc là sont forts chez flamoval a alors
le dernier témoin basse et c'est vous
monsieur billy solstice donc
milliardaire texan ruiné et longtemps
financier du président lyndon johnson
que vous accuser d'avoir fait tuer john
kennedy pour qu'ils arrêtent de fouiner
dans les magouilles de johnson c'est ça
c'est ça
alors là faire et est sorti dans paris
match elle sera développée lundi soir
dans lundi investigation sur canal +
sous le titre jeff qui autopsie d'un
complot voilà alors on va reprendre les
choses de 0,1 pour que tout le monde
comprenne bien et tout le monde puisse
suivre alors le 22 novembre 63 john
fitzgerald kennedy est assassiné à
dallas quelques heures plus tard lee
harvey oswald est arrêté mais il est
immédiatement abattus par jack ruby
avant d'avoir eu le temps de s'expliquer
voilà un crédit qu'on surnommait
l'assassin de l'assassin voilà alors la
révélation du livre que vous publiez
tous les deux c'est qu'en fait il y
avait un deuxième tireur oswald n'étais
pas seul dans le dépôt de livres au
cinquième étage en face de l'endroit où
kennedy a été assassiné auprès de lui
dites vous il y aurait eu un autre
tireur un dénommé malcolm est vrai toit
l'as tu as au service du lobby pétrolier
texan
tueur dont on n'a retrouvé l'empreinte
digitale sur place donc déjà prenons ce
point vous dites qu'il y avait deux
tireurs face à cannes et
lui avait il y avait deux tireurs l'un
d'entre eux était mal comme l'un et
l'autre étaient onze osgood
qu'est ce qui vous permet de dire que
wallace est elle à ce jour là au
cinquième étage du dépôt de livres c'est
le point de départ en fait de l'enquète
c'est la découverte
en 98 d'une empreinte déclassés par les
enquêteurs de l'époque classé anonyme et
lorsqu'on la compare à un suspect qui
met mal comme wallace on se rend compte
qu'en des plus grands experts américains
trouvent 33 points 3,33 points de
comparaison aux états unis il faut
savoir si point de comparaison suffisent
pour envoyer quelqu'un à la chaise
électrique layana 33 il y en a 30 euros
donc cette empreinte elle est
formellement identifié ans et pour des
raisons techniques je prêt expliqué ici
qu'elle a été déposée au moment du crime
donc c'est la preuve qu'il y avait à
côté de lee harvey oswald un deuxième
tireur à dallas le vin d'honneur 63 la
voilà qui est ce malcolm everett wallace
qui donc était au
travail et pour le dow jones en ligue 1
je connaissais déjà dans les années 40
c'était déjà un tueur à gages et c'était
un très bon tireur d'élite et un est
clair que la bio gagés
il avait commencé à travailler dans les
années 40 pour le lobby il était à
marshall un shérif à l'époque quelques
carter était à être été le prince ne le
conseiller du prince c'est lui qui a mis
en place le réseau politique de johnson
c'est lui qui faisait les la connexion
entre johnson et les ailes et financier
texan donc ce mal comme wallace était un
tueur à gages au service du lobby
pétrolier texan on est bien d'accord
leur désaccord et il était à côté d'
harvey oswald le jour où harvey oswald a
tiré c'est ce que vous dites c'est ce
que je dis suivi par n'est pareil
document alors autre révélation de votre
bouquin kennedy a été touchée de face en
fait on le voit bien quand on voit les
radios de son crâne il a été touché de
face et quand on voit des photos de
kennedy on s'aperçoit qu'il a un visage
intact ce que vous dites dans votre
bouquin c'est qu'il a été réparée par un
embaumeur de génie du nom de john
liggett qui d'ailleurs n'a jamais
dévoilé son emploi du temps le 22
novembre 1963 donc kennedy a subi une
réparation faciale avant le top 6 pour
accréditer la thèse du tueur unique mais
en fait ce qu'il y avait depuis toujours
il y avait une controverse entre les
témoignages des gens qui avaient tenté
de le sauver à dallas et les gens qui a
fait l'autopsié à washington plus tard
et les témoignages officiels certifiés
ne correspondait pas moi un jour on ne
parle billy me parle de ce john league
est
un baume heures réputé qui a travaillé
sur le corps de jane mansfield
lorsqu'elle était décapité et lorsqu'on
va pour la première fois je me dis ça y
est on est parti dans x-files parce que
là l'intérêt c'est un petit peu fort
mais je retrouve la femme de ses ligues
est qu'ils me racontent que le 22
novembre 63 et s'intéresse pas du tout
aller faire kennedy quelques quelques
minutes avant que la mort de guéi soit
lancé on appelait ligue est on là on lui
a dit on a besoin de toi pour faire
quelque chose sur le président et il
disparaît pendant 24 heures et lorsqu'il
va revenir après il dit maintenant
partout de dallas il met tous dans la
voiture toute sa famille il se retrouve
à dans le sud du texas il se met devant
la télé il fume cigarette sur cigarette
et lorsqu'ils voient lee harvey oswald
se faire assassiner il dit maintenant
c'est bon on peut rentrer cette
histoire-là été extrêmement forte et
pour moi le demander vérification parce
que je pouvais pas sortir une histoire
comme ça sinon j'avais passé encore pour
un fou et donc j'ai retrouvé la personne
par exemple qui ce jour là est partie
avec les guettent et quand on lui
demande ce qui faisait le 22 novembre 63
il dit je ne m'en souviens pas je ne
m'en souviens pas je ne dit pas ce que
vous dites est faux mais je ne m'en
souviens pas donc vous ce que vous dites
cycliques est ce jour-là à réparer le
visage de kennedy pour faire croire
qu'il avait été tué par un seul tir
finalement ça serait l'explication la
plus simple et la plus logique de la
différence entre que lorsqu'on voit le
film âpre odeur le film raté le pays
explose veut dire le fils de 26 secondes
qui est le fils unique de l'assassinât
lakki marwat réalisé par monsieur âpre
odeur voilà il en est donc dans le pour
la première fois en france dans le
documentaire lundi on va montrer une
version qui a été nettoyé
de manière digitale et on voit bien
toute la partie avant la tête de kennedy
tomber et lorsqu'on voit les photos il a
plus rien donc c'est une espèce c'est
pour moi l'explication la plus simple
même si au départ me paraissait fort
bien
c'est exactement ça c'est une histoire
toute simple les gens essaient de la
rendre plus compliquée qu'elle ne l'est
en fait l'histoire est toute simple
alors bref le complot selon vous a été
organisé par le vice président lyndon
johnson qui trouvait les frères qu'elle
est ni trop curieux il pensait que les
frères kennedy s'intéresser trop assez
assez à faire
billy à l'époque où vous étiez riche
vous avez considérablement arroser le
président lyndon johnson qui était
encore un politicien local vous l'avez
aider vous avez été en contact avec
johnson a été son financiers à l'époque
c'est vrai oui effectivement lundi ce
que vous donnez dans le bouquin
malheureusement vous le donner à la fin
et on espère lundi soir sur canal qu on
en apprendra plus dans l'ain petit
investigations vous possédez billy une
cassette ou cliff carter qui est donc un
membre de la durée zoo 10 ans du lobby
johnson vous dit textuellement lyndon en
parlant de lyndon johnson vice-président
lyndon n'aurait pas dû donner à mac
c'est wallace l'ordre de tuer kennedy
oui je sais
[Musique]
c'est tout à fait exact
lorsque nous avons enregistré cette
cassette la règle les feux avaient peur
de
d'avoir des problèmes donc on avait
enregistré cette cassette avec pelé fait
moi même pas cette cassette du cese ne
sert d'assurance vie pratiquement alors
si jamais j'ai un problème j'envoie un
mois à mon avocat est là et la bande
sera produit à urt et qu est ce que vous
nous dites la bbc que c'est une cassette
dans laquelle cliff parker dénonce
lyndon johnson comme non pas l'assassin
enfin en tous les cas l'organisateur de
l'assassinât de john fitzgerald kennedy
c'est exactement ça et lyndon johnson
se sont rencontrés
à organiser
côté l'assassinât alors c'était il à
faire un peu trop compliqué pour eux ils
ont délégué aventure professionnelle ne
savais pas que des tueurs ne savais pas
ce qu'était des engeances ouais c'était
des gamins qui se disait que les kennedy
c'est des gamins de boston qui savait
pas ce qui se passait
j'ai demandé à monsieur pourquoi ils en
parlent qu'aujourd'hui pourquoi vous en
parlez qu'aujourd'hui billy
la seule raison pour laquelle j'en parle
aujourd'hui c'est que bon certainement
j'ai eu d'autres occasions par le passé
mais
on voulait savoir ce qui est écrit
lyndon johnson ce qu'il avait fait
l'histoire de sa vie de la mienne et les
assassinats elles étaient des accidents
de parcours des mets et non des frères
guénot qui
il aurait dû se méfier du clan texan il
n'avait pas n'était pas de taille à
affronter la cour des grands et le clan
texan lyndon avait besoin de se
débarrasser des canadiens parce que
justement il s'il n'avait pas été du
président lui-même il passait la chaise
électrique le gard alors vous dites
aujourd'hui bon vous êtes vous êtes
ruiner un million je crois qu'on peut le
dire vous êtes veuf vous êtes ces ag et
et vous dites je vais tout dire mais
pourquoi ne dites vous pas tout pourquoi
dites-vous seulement cette phrase de
cliff carter lyndon n'aurait pas dû
donner l'ordre pourquoi est-ce que vous
balancez pas tout compte tenu de votre
âge de votre situation
j'ai passé les dernières années de ma
vie en taule comme la queue
ou aller sur la chaise électrique moi
même et pourquoi faites-vous ces
révélations en france plutôt qu'aux
états unis
c'est à dire que je n'ai pas tellement
voulu parler aux journalistes
certes le caisson a été donné par le
passé mais
quand vous vouliez on a commencé à
travailler sur ce livre
on s'est rapprochés ça s'est passé très
simplement je faisais confiance à lui
bien alors william jean lesieur dans
télé 7 jours affirme que les révélations
de votre livre sont déjà dans le domaine
public est trouvable en 30 minutes sur
internet il suffit d'aller sur google de
taper billy solstice plus john kennedy
et on y retrouve tout ce que vous avez
mis des années à dénicher jean lesieur
parle d'une part à parle du téléfilm une
du documentaire c'est que ces voix parle
du documentaire ait pas de lui et pas du
lift qu'il n'avait pas encore lu jean
lesieur nous fait un procès d'intention
sûr sûr sûr ce documentaire là pour des
raisons complètement fausses et
personnel et moi ce qui me choque le
plus dans ce nom dans cette espèce de
mini polémique lancée par télé 7 jours
qui n'est pas suivi par le reste de la
presse qui a vu le documentaire qui
l'adoré ou qu'elle lui livrer qu'il aime
ce qui me choque le plus avec jean
lesieur sait que c'est quelqu'un qu'on a
eue au téléphone bernard nicolas et moi
pendant plus d'une heure à lui expliqué
que la première personne à avoir parlé
de mac wallace c'était moi dans un
précédent livre en 97 et que c'était le
format jef k autopsie d'un crime d'état
et c'est cette information-là qui avait
été reprise sur internet et comme je lui
avais dit mais savez-vous monsieur ce
qu'on dit sur vous sur internet est ce
que ça veut dire ce que c'est vrai il
était resté sans voix il nous avait
expliqué aussi que il était extrêmement
sensible à tout ce qu'on disait sur les
états unis et que donc il n'avait pas
aimé notre documentaire c'est son sens
droite pas aimer mais ce qui est
choquant c'est que ces arguments sont
complètement fous pas vous savez quand
même gamme que depuis 40 ans il ya eu de
nombreuses théories du complot qui
s'opposaient aux conclusions de la
commission warren ya eu jim garrison
popularisé par le film de oliver stone
lui parlait d'un dénommé kleisch aux
agents de la cia qui auraient été en
fait l'assassin et puis a eu des
centaines d'ouvragés ou les
commanditaires ont été tour à tour la
cia la mafia castro les soviétiques
l'extrême droite
johnson enfin y'a que la famille ewing
cap a été accusée quoi pas et encore je
pense que julien est un prochain livre
qui se prépare qui accusent la famille
bush je vous le dis donc non c'est vrai
la littérature kennedy est immense je
crois que c'est un des sujets qu'elle
plus été traités là je pense que pour la
première fois un journalisme disait ça
que lorsqu'on finit le livre on ne
ressort pas avec plus de questions qu au
départ moi la dernière phrase du livre
c'est demain je serai ailleurs parce que
pour moi j'ai le sentiment que cette
enquête la gelée terminé
il reste il reste des il reste des
questions forcément parce que parce que
j'ai pas la prétention de répondre de
répondre à tous mais pour la première
fois le c'est un livre qui est constitué
des normes énormément de preuves il ya
il ya un cahier photos vous avez des
annexes avec des avec des documents
totalement inconnu et des témoignages de
gens qui étaient au texas qui n'avait
jamais parlé et que 40 ans après il
parle pour la première fois
pourquoi votre version ska la bonne
parce que j'avance à rome
ce que j'avance des preuves et ça c'est
une c'est une première tout le monde est
parti dans des théories là vous avez des
documents vous avez la cassette et
surtout j'ai pu prouver que billy sol
était celui qui disait et une fois que
vous prouver que billy sol est vraiment
le conseil johnson vous pouvez le croire
et puis j'ai entendu j'ai entendu cette
cassette enregistrée en 71 ou clive
carter explique que lyndon johnson a
donné l'ordre d'abattre kennedy
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc william reymond et billy
solstice le livre s'appelle jfk le
dernier témoin c'est publié chez
flammarion qu'est-ce que vous avez des
questions les les archives les archers
de la cia elles sont pas ouvertes toutes
les cinquante ans aux états unis vous
savez les archives il faut pas trop
fantasmer dessus parce que les archives
on y met sur la sq on a bien envie de 10
mètres sont des traces écrites ce sont
des rapports l'assassinât de kennedy
s'est pas décidée par écrit il n'y a pas
de courrier la poste correspondance
instruit tout ce qu'ils voulaient
détruire tout ce qui pourrait être
imitée quelques uns il le balance bien
merci beaucoup la suite c'est leur
maison à paris compte d'éditeurs qui à
venir dans quelques semaines vous
démontrez de parapluies ce big buck
livre je vous le souhaite mais y en aura
c'est normal c'est normal il est vrai
contradicteur avec de vrais arkema en
panne aura moins qu'ils s'opposeraient
on veut pas le côté merci beaucoup merci
à tous les deux
non pour continuer la conversation en
sambre nord et moi moi moi je pense que
on va prendre plein plein de trucs plein
de gros scandale avec des mecs comme ça
qu'ils vont arriver en fin de vie avec
pas trop de responsabilités pas trop
d'enfants derrière eux et qu'ils vont
lâcher des gros morceaux 20 et les gros
morceaux viendront de ce type de
personnes amendées hui les ruines et il
est veuf et il raconte que sa femme
qu'il adorait qui s'appelait patsy qui
se mêlaient jamais de ses affaires un
jour lui a dit ça je crois qu'il faut
que tu en parles et voilà c'est pour ça
qu'ils c'est pour ça qu'il en parlait ce
que c'est vrai ce que c'était
sinequa partir sur un beau coup d'éclat
il apprend rien à perdre non plus et
maintenant
emma
ouais si gilles delluc
alors philippe quel bilan faites-vous de
cette émission tous les cas de la partie
dont vous avez été témoin pour vos
impressions la chine a décliné vu de
l'extérieur alors moi je suis d'accord
avec comment s'appelait-il william
reymond chez reavie ça le style avec
woody je suis d'accord moi je pense
qu'il ya eu de la magouille derrière
tout ça
magnifique bien ça va bien et vous très
bien écouter on est là vous connaissez
judith godrèche celle magnifique judith
godrèche hélène ségara et deuxième
spéciale sans foie gras vous connaissez
nos amis alors on m'a dit que c'était du
foie gras de votre grand mère
non mais attendez mais vous la gav et
comment vous obtenez ça
parce que là c'est vous qui commande
qu'ils allaient l'agavé bonnes réponses
hélène ségara on a parlé dans taxi
catherine barma confisqué le pot de foie
gras et on n'a plus le droit je pense
que vous avez dit à catherine non plus
trois mois je leur ai lancé un appel je
vois qu'on libère ce pot de foie gras
qui vient demander lario l'otage en
régie j'aimerais qu'il revienne sur le
plateau à tout le monde a droit à un
avocat au moins alors vous êtes toujours
avec ruquier avec twitter vous avez déjà
vendu c'est incroyable vous êtes déjà
vendu quatre millions d'exemplaires de
la bd le chat par an
tout va bien et même encore mieux depuis
que les beaux-arts mesdames messieurs
les beaux-arts de paris vous consacre
une exposition philippe delluc pour les
20 ans du chat c'est un lieu du 28
octobre 4 janvier et si la première fois
grand ranelagh des plaisirs on rogne sur
la personne qui a eu cet honneur
jerson personnel avant même de son
vivant même deux sont morts est inverse
ils annulaient jamais l'école des
beaux-arts n'avait ouvert ses portes à
la bande dessinée ou au dessin d'humour
donc j'inaugure
non voilà on regarde à quoi ça ressemble
philippe geluck
marié do
je voulais vous raconter en deux mots à
quoi va servir ce que vous faites
aujourd'hui vous allez à paraître dans
le mur vidéo de l'exposition on a filmé
les 300 façon de faire le chat celle ci
est sans doute la plus originale
il vient de rentrer du kosovo j'en ai
deux sont d'autres qui sont à kaboul
pour le moment on fait un boulot sérieux
dont je ne sont pas toujours recherché
la conséquence
voilà vidic alors
c'est non et non est-ce que depuis cet
épisode philippe geluck vous êtes devenu
militariste non mais alors est-ce qu'on
peut dire que caen et militariste quand
on aime l'armée belge comme ça
j'arrivais pas militarisme il aime
raconter quoi de voir l'armée belge en
totalité d'un seul coup je me dis que si
on attaquer l'ennemi comme ça au moins
ça les frères ainsi que les frais ont
pour les rendre et et j'ai envoyé une
lettre au ministère de la défense
nationale j'ai reçu un coup de fil du
ministre qui me l'a dit je trouve l'idée
formidable je trouve l'idée formidable
oui mais je veux aller belge stromae
nico dans les airs la nasa pourrait
arriver qu'en belgique ou alors rentré
du alors hitler aurait pu faire diffuser
des trucs comme ça bien rangé j'ai des
croix gammées c'est moins rigolo non
idiak alors la belgique dont je pensais
que c'était un pays où tout allait mal
et puis je me rends compte que c'est un
pays où on peut encore rêver ouais si on
peut faire des choses et puis l'armée
belge n'est pas débordé non plus ouais
on peut le député ils sont kosovo ils
sont à kaboul sortie tous les gardes
c'est incroyable d'un maitien pacifisme
alors l'expo donc c'est aux beaux-arts
de paris et puis aussi la parution du
douzième album de lush a un qui
s'appelle et vous chavaz philippe vous
savez que ce soir nous avons avec nos
gîtes godrèche qui était à l'affiché
d'un film qui s'appelle france boutique
avec françois cluzet karin viard
nathalie baye vous dis bien à nous ont
dit parmi nous oui j'ai des terminaux
vous comprenez un
hollande au xixe laval
j'ai vraiment parmi ce soir et judith
godrèche et alain pékin affiche d'un
film s'appelle france boutique avec
karin viard et françois cluzet nathalie
baye et c'est un film sur le télé achat
à achat
c'est un risque d'être amis judith
godrèche vent très très bien des
produits absolument insensé alors si
vous vous deviez nous vendre le douzième
album du chat vous feriez comment pour
vous le vendre ouais mais je voulais
offert vous allez pas me l'acheter vous
n'êtes pas idiots non plus aux
téléspectateurs pourquoi est-ce qu'on
doit acheter le douzième album alors
qu'on avait déjà 11 à la maison et
simplement parce que c'est le meilleur
thierry à parce que nous nous ne les
voit faire nous voyons là l'oeuvre d'un
artiste en progrès constant vrai qui
atteint un sommet 1 et qui est très
malade et donc c'était que son dernier
album aura pas mal
branchée qu'elle était très dernier
pourquoi on est malade qu'on voit un
film ou un livre toujours faire quoi et
je suis papa n'y ait pas ces derniers
c'est pas mal je passe tous annoncer
l'album qui va changer il a fait ça
d'être allemand c'est ce qu'on va lire
et gère le chat va crever ou dernier
album j'ai failli appeler le le livre le
dernier shah et mon éditeur ne voulait
pas moins pour moi c'était le dernier de
ces gens là alors vous ressembler de
plus en plus je trouve à votre créature
lorsque vous êtes déjà rendu compte de
ça est-ce que vous perdez vos poils oui
j'en fais des pinceaux est ce que vous
vous frottez comme ça contre michel
drucker oui non qu'est ce que vous
faites bien est ce que vous faites vos
griffes sur laurent ruquier
il il a aidé il a la dent dure je griffe
parfois 90 complète bien ça ça est-ce
que vous jouez pendant des heures comme
le chat avec un bouchon et bruno masure
jouer bruno masure parfois pendant des
heures non est-ce que vous émettez des
pieds nus quand votre femme vous prend
par la peau du cou oui est ce que vous
aimez les chattes j'en raffole bien on
va vous faire philippe geluck un anti
portrait chinois
[Musique]
j'ai lu que si vous étiez une injure
vous feriez quoi une injure bas mais non
mais ne veut souffler pas abordé le
maire de fait chier de ta mère de
mes deux matches et y est une maladie la
silly kull gérer ce que c'est ah non
c'est une maladie génétique rare ouais
c'est les gens qui au lieu d'avoir la
raie des fesses verticale long
horizontale non mais attendez déco n'est
pas parce que c'est grave parce que si
vous glissez par exemple sur une rampe
d'escalier en qu'hilton et qu'il est
normal ça fait si vous souffrez
pellicule ça fait
un accident cardio vasculaire un vice
vice président des états unis dont le
président des ja avis en lui-même
d'ampleur un supplice
suppositoire la télé réalité artak
supplice du pal pour un chat qui a pas
passé
si vous étiez une cicatrice jeu très
bonne maîtrise du pal pour un chef c'est
la ville ainsi qu'à prier pour que tu
peux partir merci
je tempère une ci dessus
l'aurore et voilà
si vous y étiez
c'est une cicatrice là une cicatrice au
monsieur un jour ouvert le bras comme ça
et ma femme était ce jour-là enceinte de
huit mois et demi nous on était à
l'étranger en tchécoslovaquie on est
arrivé à l'hôpital ils ont cru que c'est
elle qui venait pour accoucher ils l'ont
emmené en et moi je suis resté là le
saigner dans la salle d'attenté fait
avant qu'elle puisse leur expliquer en
tchécoslovaquie
c'était pour moi keeper des bons sens
voilà si vous étiez un poison le hareng
bon alors il ya dix ans un poisson un
poison
mais beaucoup de harengs ça peut être
toxique et finalement à faire 50 le foie
gras de mes élèves bien j'en parle plus
une infirmité
vous
si vous étiez un assassin alors là
franchement le deuxième tireur de kenny
parce qu'au moins je saurai si vous
étiez une p la télé réalité
si vous étiez une torture de la télé
réalité si vous étiez une humiliation
perdre dans un truc de télé réalité
vous étiez
plus qu'un terroriste nikos aliagas
[Musique]
al bundy
c'est vision questerre
j'accueille maintenant pierre botton
[Musique]
valet
pierre botton bonsoir vous êtes devenu
un auteur prolixe puisque après mes
chers amis et il y a toujours des
complices vous publié chez flammarion
j'aime la vie comment remonter la pente
c'est le récit d'une résurrection la
vôtre la naissance du nouveau pierre
botton ils arrêtent le récit de vos
forfaits voilà un message un must
comment remonter la pente forfait à
c'est la dette un peu mais c'est
pas un montage ne sera pas alors monté
très monte alors dont celui vous parlez
du pierre botton d'avant celui d'avant
la mort et la résurrection
vous dites avancées comme un bulldozer
ne prenons garde à personne et vous
parlez de vos parents détruit par la
saisie de leurs meubles à cause de
l'ancien pierre botton de vos enfants en
larmes quand les huissiers saisissent
les peluches des enfants avec qui
l'ancien pierre botton n'avait jamais
pris 1 n'avait jamais pris un bain donc
cet ancien pierre breton vous le vous le
détestez aujourd'hui vous devrez vous
renier pour le lui sied aussi un parlant
il faut bien ils ont des enfants les
huissiers aussi consacré celui-ci lui
disent les peluches
huissiers sont des pervers barbare quand
ils ont des gosses chez pas enfin ils en
sont les cadeaux ils ont offert des
cadeaux et lorsque ça s'est passé j'ai
effectivement téléphoner en disant vous
êtes sûr vous avez le droit de prendre
les jouets des enfants et on m'a répondu
mais - quand et c'est une phrase qui
épate complètement idiote d'ailleurs
quand je vais dans les cités les enfants
jouent avec des cartons donc vos enfants
joueront avec des cartes voilà vous avez
à propos de huissiers et de saisie vous
savez ce que le professeur choron hara
kiri avait fait parce que s'ils étaient
régulièrement saisi par les huissiers
qui prenait les meubles raid 1 et donc
il y avait fait construire des meubles
plus grand que les portes et les
fenêtres ils n'ont jamais pu les sortir
en tout cas en tout cas ce que j'écris
dans le livre c'est qu'il faut accepter
tout cela et essayer de se dire que
c'est vraiment l'analyse qu'il faut
faire à la base si on veut essayer de se
relever ces deux toujours considéré
qu'on est à l'origine de cela six très
honnêtement si j'avais pas fait les
excès étaler ma fortune et ainsi de
suite je n'aurais pas eu ce retour là la
meilleure preuve c'est qu'aujourd'hui je
crois que j'étale ce que je suis et j'ai
un retour tout à fait différent est ce
que vous allez être aussi bon que vous
avez été mauvais j'en sais rien je
cherche pas être bon on cherche surtout
avec moi même voilà vous êtes dans la
rédemption il est dans la rédemption
exactement le rôle anciens pierre botton
n'existe plus aujourd'hui vous avez en
face de vous le nouveau pierre botton
qui est reparti de zéro après la taule
c'est ça moi bordeaux - 0 passé quand on
fait une première fois le parti de zéro
la sépare de -22 millions de moins 22
millions voilà alors d'abord
effectivement il faut admettre
alors d'abord ce que ce soit vous dites
dans votre bouquin pierre botton sekita
a mis un album est la réalité de la
faute vous dites oui la justice a eu
raison de me condamner dont seulement 6
h 10 que la justice a sauvé ma vie c'est
quelque chose qui choque beaucoup à la
fois mes co-détenues les avocats tout
cela ouais mais la justice a sauvé ma
vie derrière les anciens c'est quoi qui
nous arrive dans notre vie on a toujours
une part de responsabilité c'est même
dans un pot de mauvaises rillettes
je pense qu'on est joint défectueux
relais pour la vie y est dit le maire
non mes chéris
mortalité l'oms recommande rillettes qui
était du foie gras l'alabama selon le
jugement était père d'éthique pas
le grand responsable et deux boutons
c'est l'argent rentre et il vous dit
mais c'est assez marrant c'est un peu
naïf et c'est moi c'est des trucs qu'on
m'a dit quand j' avais je pas dix ans
mais vous dites c'est pas l'argent qu'il
faut mettre au sommet de son échelle de
valeur c'est la famille sais pas quel
âge vous avez mais c'est quand même fou
que vous ayez attendu cet âge là pour le
pour le comprendre on vous l'avait dit
quand vous vous voyez quand vous étiez
petit ça non mais non seulement ça vous
croyez pas qu'on est élevé dans une
société où les tous les codes de la
réussite sont des codes de décote par
rapport au reste de la société les
gamins dans les banlieues ils veulent
des chaussures de marque qui valent à
fric fou on est pris dans une dans une
enveloppe dans des pressions qui amène à
plutôt avoir une réussite sociale n'est
pas neuf mois c'est pas tellement leurs
jambes dans lequel je courais là c'est
la réussite sociale
parce que si je suis j'ai basculé avec
avec la politique fait très honnêtement
qui la richesse prochaine toute
possession est un esclave à sion c'est
jésus asseyez vous êtes de vue c'est
jésus la maman mais c'est c'est comme si
un être excessif forcément j'ai vu j'ai
eu j'ai cru que l'argent a donné
beaucoup de choses et aujourd'hui c'est
faut obligatoirement gr un certain
dégoût vis-à-vis de cela c'est non
seulement un dégoût mais une peur j'ai
c'est une bd peur que j'avais je suis
obligé de travailler pour rembourser
tout ce que je dois tout ce que je dois
rembourser on va t'aider mais je trie on
va pas te laisser dans la merde on va
lancer un bouton taux n'ont pas facile à
dire mais avant tout en revanche
sérieusement si vous êtes imaginez qu'on
vous ait pas choper à l'époque vous
seriez peut-être plus heureux non non
certainement pas mais je pense que si tu
savais ce qu'est ce qui vous a non
seulement votre pièce qu'ils m'accordent
mais qu'est ce qui permet d'imaginer
l'imaginer voilà vous aider michel noir
vous apprendrez tout pour lui devient
président de la république aujourd'hui
vous seriez sont conseillés tout ça vous
seriez au sommet du pays et alors
aujourd'hui moi je suis très heureux de
de l'avis que j'ai des rapports humains
en plus pendant dix ans est très jeune
j'ai eu la chance de voir énormément de
choses de comprendre une amende chose de
lire à travers les lignes et nommant
deux choses m'ont très honnêtement j'en
ai fait le tour et se et et de la
personnalité humaine et de la richesse
humaine j'en ai par quel tour des
risques a pas chez vous aujourd'hui
pierre botton une grosse part d'auto
persuasion tire une méthode coué se dire
vu que je suis ruiné autant dire que
c'est ça le bonheur puisque je peux
comparer les deux situations
aujourd'hui c'est les vacances scolaires
je suis avec mes mais mes trois filles
je suis très heureux et je compare par
rapport à ceux lorsque j'en avais que
deux que j'avais un appartement un hôtel
particulier de 1250 mètres carrés je ne
voyais pas je n'avais pas et j'avais pas
la relation que j'ai avec mes filles
aujourd'hui voilà donc c'est quelque
chose de très fort de très intenses je
peux comparer entre l'argent et ce que
je vis aujourd'hui mais je suis passé du
tout matériel au tout humain je dirais
et et surtout et surtout à la une
recherche sur sur moi même que je ne
faisais pas et je dis j'ai des choses à
renvoyer j'ai des choses à renvoyer aux
gens qui sont à sainte anne
chez les psys quand on dit il faut une
fille suit une thérapie mois avant ça me
faisait rire non je voudrais là aussi
dire bah il faut le faire je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens qui doivent se faire
aider j'ai pris tous les médicaments les
anxiolytiques on peut penser je les ai
pris là ce soir c'est je viens devant
vous j'ai pas un médicament ils sont
supporters c'est ce que vous dites est
très juste je me souviens de vous venons
dans cette émission bourré de
tranquillisants tremblant incapable de
parler mais ayant appelé quatre fois
avant pour ce chantier avec vous et ce
soir vous êtes tout à fait naturel vous
aider à bien dans votre peau et ça nous
fait plaisir voilà merci beaucoup
on regrette simplement que j'ai mis
autant d'années pour découvrir que la
famille c'est plus important que
l'argent ceci étant des enfants c'est
des trucs judo creton prendrai quand
même que je suis obligé d'en venir aux
suites judiciaires de la sphère noire
botton qui est toujours en cours le
procès s'est terminé le 16 octobre
dernier et le jugement est en délibéré
il sera rendu le 14 novembre alors
évidemment bon le procès portait sur des
versements par des entreprises de
bâtiment et travaux publics dont
bouygues d'ailleurs d'argent sur des
comptes suisses et il ya eu jusqu'à 9
millions de francs qui ont été versés
voilà alors la fille de michel noir à
mme valérie est venu expliquer à la
barre donc qu'elle avait fait des
voyages à genève pour aller chercher de
l'argent pour son père de l'argent
qu'ils avaient été émis par des
entreprises et qu'elles venaient
chercher pour son père pour aider la
carrière politique de son père alors
elle défend votre version parce que ça
c'est votre version et quand on lui
demande pourquoi elle défend sa elle dit
j'aime pierre c'est tout est ce que
c'est une raison suffisante pour
témoigner il ya deux choses qui sont
très importantes à dire thierry c'est
que c'est le parquet qui l'a fait citer
c'est à dire que moi j'ai eu plus de six
procès est ce qu'on peut imaginer quelle
aurait été le poids ce témoignage est
est ce que j'aurais été condamné à cinq
ans de prison
si anne était venu témoigner à ma
demande en 1996 donc moi j'ai toujours
souhaité qu anne valérie ne soit pas
mise au milieu de tout cela elle a été
interrogée par plus de quatre ou cinq
juges d'instruction aucun juge
d'instruction n'a souhaité organiser
cette confrontation dans le cabinet d'un
juge d'instruction entre année son père
ça eu lieu
c'est un choix qui a été fait elle a
décidé de venir ça lui appartient
respecte énormément anne valérie on
comprendra que je la respecte en dehors
du témoignage qu'elle vient de faire
puisqu'elle a répété dix fois
dans les débats on a quand même appris
un truc moi je veux bien croire vous
soyez complètement maintenant passer de
l'autre côté on se félicite on est tous
très contents de ça parce que ça fait ça
fait vraiment plaisir sur le plan vous
reprendre on n'a pas appris un truc j'ai
dit quelque chose le premier jour ouais
parce que c est ce que vous allez bien
ouais qu'est le premier jour moi
qu'est-ce que je vais le président me
pose la question et me dit vous êtes
mariés vous avez deux enfants sinon j'en
ai trois et je puis comme j'ai un devoir
de loyauté vis-à-vis de la justice parce
que je dis que la justice a sauvé ma vie
la troisième fille est également une
fille dans la mer est une des filles de
michel noir cirque donc après avoir eu
deux enfants avec anne valérie vous avez
séduit la benjamine qui s'appelle julia
et vous lui avez fait avocate un ouais
c'est dallas la danse est pas dallas
était au rêve de pasolini c'est ma vie
j'assume cet enfant qui est à l'origine
de ma résurrection en grande partie
j'assume bien entendu la relation avec
julia qui est une femme exceptionnelle
parce qu'elle m'a accompagné dans tout
mon parcours il ya des circonstances
dans la vie qui sont des circonstances
tout à fait particulière
il y a beaucoup de choses dans beaucoup
de familles dans la nôtre ces publics
j'ai choisi de le révéler à la justice
j'ai choisi de le révéler parce que j'ai
je ne veux plus rien avoir à cacher et
surtout surtout par rapport à la
troisième fille est aujourd'hui je viens
de vous dire quelque chose c'est les
vacances les trois soeurs sont ensemble
donc
je vois pas je n'ai pas à me cacher de
l'amour même si l'amour
est est à nouveau à être s'est retrouvé
à nouveau dans la famille de michel nous
on est tous aujourd'hui je suis séparé
du lien séparer de julia mais elle
devait pas écrire le livre avec vous
julia un moment voyez tout faire et
pourquoi vous l'avez pas fait parce que
les tensions sont très vives
la séparation était très vive vous savez
je le dis d'ailleurs dans le livre il ya
une chose qui est très difficile quand
quelqu'un vous accompagne dans une
période très très dur à un moment
lorsque vous sortez de prison les gens
ils voudraient vous voir robocop il
voudrait vous retrouver et
instantanément fort mais la première
chose et il voudrait que vous leur
envier tout de suite tout ce qui vous
ont donnés et elle m'a donné énormément
cette femme énormément et je me suis
trouvé dans l'incapacité de de donner
quoi que ce soit la première chose qu'il
fallait que je fasse et me reconstruire
moi même et là dedans sans doute que je
suis apparu ce que je suis en douce sans
doute encore un peu très faible c'est
très difficile de sortir et de de ne pas
pouvoir rendre tout ce qu'on vous a
donné j'en étais incapable même 1,1 d'un
donateur à la barre du tribunal a dit
mais qu'est ce que tu es devenu ils ont
dû te massacrer qu'est-ce qu'ils ont dû
te faire subir pour être ce que tu es et
je lui répondu devant le président et
trame du tribunal mais je suis fier de
ce que je suis devenu
c'est sûr j'ai eu lieu
débité sur marion
et maintenant les messieurs voici lidl
d'hélène ségara
mais
c'est
si dsk ne les pechs mode
je te l'avais promis et vaine il est la
dette gagnent de depeche mode et pour
ceux qui ont oublié qu'ils aient les
pechs mode depeche mode c'est ça
les deux
rwe
je ne
1 2
pays
m
il
sans lui
[Musique]
c
je suis
il se fait
et
sous l
[Musique]
tu
je ne sais pas
[Musique]
c'est
bien le bonsoir
beaucoup de gens en france et surtout
d'hélène ségara ici voilà il est la
touche et le hélène touché le voilà elle
a deux idoles dans sa vie c'est orlando
et vous donc voilà alors c'est vous qui
avez eue c'est vous qui avez eu l'idée
du nom depeche mode à
un veau sur malheureusement oui c'est
moi alors c'est le nom d'un magazine de
mode français pourquoi pas elles ou
marie claire
oui effectivement on aurait pu prendre
les autres j'étais écolier à l'époque
chez j'ai étudié en fait la mode et on
allait faire écran certes un petit
concert dans un pub à londres puis
n'avons pas encore de nom alors il y
avait ces magazines devant nous l'a été
et puis multiples demander quel est le
nom du groupe c'est le premier magazine
que j'ai pris j'ai dit et je dirais que
c'est peut-être nul marie claire quand
même alors des bêches mode c'était des
pionniers vous avez été les premiers à
rendre populaire la musique électronique
kraftwerk avant vous avait initié la
musique électronique
mais il avait fait d'une façon très
robotique et vous d'une façon beaucoup
plus acoustique beaucoup plus facile
pour le public on peut dire
oui c'est vrai que nous avons pris un
peu tous ces éléments
vertes et autres et qu'on pouvait faire
du bruit à partir d'autres choses qui
nous quitte à la batterie à propos
n'étaient pas de très bon guitariste ses
synthétiseurs et tout ça nous on permet
de manipuler le sont de manière
intéressante voile alors l'année de
l'apogée de depeche mode le climax du
groupe comme on dit c'est 1988 en 1987
vous aviez sorti un album qui s'appelait
music for my 6 music pour les masses
ensuite il ya une tournée qui s'appelait
transformer six tournées pour les masses
vous avez acquis à ce moment là une
célébrité mondiale île le 101e concerts
de cette tournée qui était live at the
rose bowl a été filmée par pennebaker et
il sort en dvd avec des interviews des
membres du groupe ensuite extraordinaire
c'est pennebaker il est célèbre pour un
film qui s'appelle montrer pop qui l'a
fait en 1967 qui était un film sur la
grande époque baba il n'avait jamais
entendu parler de depeche mode quand on
lui a proposé de faire un film sur le
groupe et puis il a commencé à s'y
coller il a été fasciné par vous et par
vaux femmes il vous a suivi dans une
tournée aux états unis et il a filmé le
101ème concert au rose bowl d'enquêté un
peu le climax l'apothéose du groupe on
peut dire non
et inspirant
en fait c'était surtout un documentaire
sur les femmes et sur les gens qui lui
est plutôt que sur nous mêmes et ce qui
était intéressant c'est de voir
justement toute cette annulation
ces gens qui venaient nous voir comme
des fidèles à l'église pratiquement qui
nous suivait à travers le pays
c'est ça qu'il a voulu montrer dans son
rythme heurté à ce transfert que les
gens bien pris la chose au moment du
documentaire des réseaux on l'a critiqué
pour ça mais c'est justement de sa crème
film il parlait plus de 5 e de depeche
mode c'était un truc qui s'intéressait à
cette idée que le public se faisaient
qu'à partir de rien il y avait ceux des
u7 machina on avait créé ce truc énorme
aux kabyles la publicité à la radio mais
rien d'autre et ça c'était intéressant
bruno on disait qu'ils ont été gavés
d'être super classe mais de look dans
son phrasé non c'est plus efficace que
l'accent texan réclamé même même il ya
une classe folle passée d'ip
pour
les chaînes qui le voient pas en vrai
j'ai trouvé encore mieux pour
rien
parallèlement dans pas longtemps elle
est incapable
alors vous devgan vous étiez la voix de
depeche mode donc pendant 22 ans et vous
avez sorti en mai dernier un album solo
qui s'appelle peppers monsters il faut
que je touche qui est écrit par ménage
ou alors que généralement les morceaux
ont été écrits par martin gore alors
j'en ai un peu marre d'ailleurs de
l'hégémonie de martin gore chaussures le
groupe depeche mode vous avez marre
d'être seulement une voie d'être
seulement la voix du groupe et vos idées
de chansons ont été rarement prise en
considération dans le groupe un petit
peu comme george harrison dans les
beatles d'une certaine façon
c'est pas si la comparaison est juste
disons qu'il y avait un peu de ça comme
des oufs que j'en avais un petit peu
assez de voir que nous avions créé pour
nous même quand on a passé suffisamment
d'années dans un an et il va prouver des
choses et de voir que finalement les
rôles sont parce que stéréotypé et que
sur le plan créatif finalement donné
seuil haut rien de nouveau parce que
nous étions cantonnés en quelque sorte à
l'étiquette que les nous étions donné
effectivement j'avais écrit des chansons
et puis je me suis dit que
déjà depeche mode existé et elle est
toujours être là et ici il fallait faire
un album il fallait que je sois avec
d'autres personnes et autres musiciens
il fallait me jeter un défi à mauvais et
j'ai eu la chance à part l'avocat zone
de faire oui vous avez bien un petit peu
marre d'être utilisée comme un
instrument votre voie utilisée comme un
instrument par le groupe alors vous avez
déclaré d'ailleurs aujourd'hui l'avenir
du groupe depeche mode dépend de
l'attitude de martin gore parce que on a
compris si vous laisse pas place et plus
de chansons avoue on se dirige vers le
split
en ces termes là j'ai vu partir tout
récemment à los angeles j'ai vu un de
mes concerts elle a trouvé ça bien je
n'aime pas parler tellement de depeche
mode
mais
il me semble que maintenant je me suis
ouvert une porte monnaie et j'ai
beaucoup aimé ce que j'ai vu c'est
d'abord j'aime beaucoup mon goût pour ce
faire nous allons bientôt jouer ensemble
et je peux pas je peux plus revenir en
arrière donc aussi je continue à aller
de l'avant et faire la musique et bien
sûr des clous je ferai la musique est
prêt à se partageront
palestinians qu'est ce que ça fait des
années que j'ai voulu participer au
groupe et je suis fier de sa carrière
cette dépêche mode mais ben là aussi
l'appui du groupe alors l'album
s'appelle peppers monsters les monstres
de papier est le premier single
s'appelle i need you
[Musique]
j
key orlando exige l'équipe
[Musique]
il
mais
ça
je
[Musique]
premier album
lieberman
la voix de depeche mode
voilà de gannan idiot
2 gagne c'est paper monsters ces
monstres de papier dont vous parlez en
fait vous dites que c'est des monstres
que vous vous étiez créer vous même
c'est la drogue c'est l'alcool et vous
aussi comme pierre botton vous êtes
guéri
alors à montcuq je ne sais pas si je
suis guéri je crois pas qu'on puisse
vraiment guéri il ya vraiment de
guérison à guérison mais
disons que j'ai beaucoup changé de
choses dans ma vie mais qui ne frime cdc
de cette façon je crois qu'on peut dire
que disons que je peux m'identifier un
petit peu un monsieur bouton ça
pique et beaucoup de sous donc
étant des monstres oui je parle sont
tous deux des déclins des angoisses et
le fait de pouvoir de pouvoir faire face
à ses angoisses et de faire des choses
qu'on n'aurait pas fait d'avancé parce
qu'on a créé justement des mots suppose
même nom se cache derrière ces bons
seront ma tendance à se cacher derrière
ça et puis un jour il faut quand même
dépasser cela alors votre vie est
différente maintenant vous lever tôt
vous accompagnez votre fils à l'école
vous faites de la gymnastique vous fait
du jogging les deux fils vous fier quand
vous faites des exercices vocaux enfin
tout ce à quoi
est-ce que vous savez c'est bien c'est
bien parce qu'en plus je vais vous dire
vous avez quand même je pense que vous
avez pris je sais pas quelle quantité
vous avez pris de drogue et d'alcool
dans tous les cas vous êtes vachement
bien dit bien conserver son courage est
drogué
c'est vrai c'est vrai il est bien
arrivé je me suis dit voilà ça c'est le
seul problème de ces groupes dans les
années 80 c'est qu'ils ont pas vécu
comme les z deep purple un la grosse
défoncé il ya les grosses d'un gris et
finalement je m'aperçois qu'il a vécu la
même chose mais il s'en tire superbe et
les quadragénaires c'est un bel âge pour
un homme en bois ce match là on dit non
et tu connais
quadragénaire c'est un vieux
demander son âge ou pas parce que
j'utilise des quadragénaires ue pour les
moines 41 binary tree à une époque quand
même vous vous aviez un ange gardien
avec vous qui s'appelait aident et qui
était un ancien dans un ancien drogué
cliquez vous suivait partout et c est ce
que vous l'avez toujours
non
j'ai parlé récemment avec le noël habite
à detroit dans le michigan
avec moi une fois mais
c'est quelqu'un de bien
surtout quand je suis retourné
précisément c'est pas mal d'avoir un
copain avec soit des choses hélène
ségara
je connais pas hélène ségara when she
was ionia
orlando lui a demandé de chanter autre
chose que du depeche mode comme et en
plus il avait un vrai look tu vois c'est
il s'appelle pas comme ça par hasard ils
ont
envahi vol des années 80 et de tout ce
qu'ils ont emporté tout bien on va y
voit la mort d'un chien qu'est ce que tu
fais là tu fais un char mais j'ai dit
c'est parce que il ya ma fille m'a
demandé de dessiner un chat alors j'ai
décidé à chaki ceux qui se shootent avec
une seringue dans laquelle il ya des
souris un ses biens durables elles sont
un peu dures à passer dans l'hémicycle
en tous les cas en parlant de sa dette
gagnent quand vous repensez maintenant à
cette époque c'est-à-dire à los angeles
quand vous étiez lacéré les poignets
avec une lame de rasoir quand vous
pensez à l'overdose que vous avez fait
au speed ball au sunset marquis hôtel à
berlin mais je me rappelle pas tout ça
mais enfin quand vous pensez à ça
aujourd'hui à cette époque de hockey
ça fait partie de mon parcours de ma
ville en
ce que je peux dire c'étaient des choix
que j'avais fait à l'époque
quand on en fait trop comme pour tout
bon c'est vrai que vous êtes mort
pendant savez que vous êtes mort pendant
deux minutes quand vous avez fait cette
overdose autres 67 marquage
effectivement je crois que j'étais on
m'a emmené à l'hosto jeu par le home a
dit ça après coup effectivement je ne le
savais pas sur le banc des
froids c'est ce genre d'histoire un
petit peu rasoir mais
je me rendais comme je faisais
je me disais mais c'est son équipe mais
il a fallu que j'arrive à ce stade là
pour me rendre compte de la bêtise ce
que je faisais je me rendais compte que
c'était débile et jusque là je crois que
je m'amusais mais c'était pas c'était
pas très bon est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
pourriez dire aux gens qui vous
regardent aux gens qui nous regardent
que la drogue c'est sympa au départ
qu'on en prend pour être bien et puis qu
au bout d'un mois deux mois trois mois
on en prend juste pour pas être mal et
que ça devient un enfer
que l'on recompte les problèmes avec
l'alcool
y'a pas de faire la différence la drogue
qu'on veut dire
qu'ils ont parlé des choses qui
paraissent acceptables au départ et puis
qui entraîne des problèmes par la suite
justement à cause des excès
et chez
je me suis battu publiquement contre la
drogue beaucoup pas été public et et
j'ai voulu effectivement l'aide du
public dans
tout ce que je peux espérer c'est que
aujourd'hui moi même je puisse faire
quelque chose de positif par rapport à
tout ça j'ai la chance de pouvoir être
au cola à faire de la musique
d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
je me suis lancé là dedans au départ
j'ai la chance d'avoir eu une deuxième
chance de m'en sortir
je crois qu'il faut pouvoir demander de
l'aide qu'elle cache pas que c'est la
chose la plus difficile pour quelqu'un
qui ne vient pas c'est moi j'ai eu la
chance d'abord autour de moi des gens
qui travaillaient pour voir avec moi
quelques vrais amis mon manager de la
funk et là aussi qui m'a aidé
ça
h
jdo
merci d'avoir été avec joseph ségura
je
oui
j'accueille maintenant manque 1000 mah
[Musique]
ahmad villemin bonsoir vous publié chez
plon un livre qui s'appelle monsieur
lévy et ce monsieur lévis et bernard
henri lévy à qui vous avez décidé de
consacrer un livre le pitch de votre
bouquin qui s'appelle donc monsieur lévy
sait comment devenir soi même en
cherchant bhl c'est ça il ya quelque
chose sans doute de la quête identitaire
mais aujourd'hui de 35 ans donc quand
j'ai mes premières passions adolescentes
que bâle henri lévy pardon j'avais 17 18
ans dont un avec tout ce que cela peut
comporter comme pathos comme excès comme
sentimentalisme et c'est vous dire que
35 ans et la prétention de penser que
mes passions sont raisonnés
donc il ya la quête d'identité mais les
identités vous savez c'est je crois que
c'est quelque chose qui est factice
c'est du jeu beaucoup mois bernard henri
lévy je crois que comme j'aime la
littérature gelé d'abord perçu comme un
personnage du roman de fiction lors
certains c'est c'est solal autres c'est
julien sorel les jibuls drieu la
rochelle moi c'était bhl que je voyais
plus comme un personnage de roman que
comme un être de chair alors qu'au
départ vous êtes une espèce de génie de
la commune a quand vous êtes petit
faisait très très brillant on vous parle
de polytechnique alors vous vous dites
faudra être à la fois poli et technique
ce qui va pas qui va pas être ça me
ferait le pas très bien ah et puis vous
raconter votre vie comme ça c'est très
bien écrit le problème de la télévision
c'est quand on a des livres qui sont
valables par leur style on a beaucoup de
mal à en parler il ya voilà vous parler
de la mort de votre père qui sait c'est
très très touchant c'est très bien écrit
mais la voilà à quoi je ne peux que
conseiller à nos amis dont on croit
tirer quand on vous écoute thermale
lisez la page 105 allez-y
et puis papa est mort alors j'ai pas pu
devient grand où je suis devenu grand
trop vite on n'est pas dans un roman là
on n'est pas dans l'histoire de la mort
matamore brutale héroïque belle
fantasmatique on est dans la mort
brouillonne la lente celle qui s'annonce
qui envoie ses émissaires qui fait des
signes de loin des coucous des clins
d'oeil des bras d'honneur pour la forme
c'est sa petite fleur gaulle à elle vous
aurez tous
non c'est bien de l'espace et c'est trés
nanar c'est très très bien écrit alors
vous raconter votre vie bon
malheureusement là on la lira pas avec
votre style
vous commencez vous faites le ménage
dans des appartements dans des
résidences d'été à la rochelle
l'après-midi et le matin vous vendez des
fromages de sève sur les sur les marchés
mais je commence surtout en écoutant un
musicien que que je regrette de ne pas
avoir croisé sur le plateau qui était il
ya une ghilane ya quinze jours
pour moi c'était la période du hard rock
était une forme urbain lyon a c'est
assez intense et kidira drogue ou
rock'n'roll de façon générale quand
c'est vécu un petit peu intensément ça
veut dire qu'on se marginalise un petit
peu volontairement la société ouais donc
effectivement j'ai raté les études à 16
ans je faisais ce que je faisais un bep
de dactylographie l'invs est un agent
des services informatiques américain
extraordinaire et puis j'ai repris les
études à 22 ans parce que précisément je
crois que d'un art henri lévy mais
d'autres évidemment m'ont donné un petit
peu le goût à la fois de la littérature
de la conscience de soi de du devenir du
monde s'est passé parler en fait ce
qu'on peut dire excuse moi bruno mais un
jour vous voyez sur antenne 2 la
diffusion d'une émission de bernard
unedic s'appelle t les aventures de la
liberté et à partir de ce moment là la
parole de bernard lévy commençait très
importante pour vous j'essaie de
révélation pour vous mais la parole de
bernard henri levy me fait l'effet d'un
tir de ak47 dans une loge d'opéra est ce
que c'est le mort elle avait la
révélation est quand même difficile pour
moi entendre c'est une connotation et
jusqu'à pas la mienne sur un laïc
militants militare
mais c'est vrai que je découvre cette
émission au moment précisément où
j'écoute alors maiden metallica et aux
gens des fromages de chèvre et c'est bon
et je moi j'avais arrêté les études à
l'époque la plupart de mes amis avaient
continué et je me suis une soirée on
était je crois que tu es à poitiers
veine sait où une soirée d'étudiants qui
étaient donc au dessus de moi parce que
moi je m'étais arrêté au bepc même pas
si je les ai eus et le sujet vient
brutalement se vendent à henri lévy et
là je vois une espèce de chape de plomb
qui tombe de mépris voilà ce que je
constate que j'ai constaté tout de suite
intuitivement à 17 18 ans et qu' il
était de bon ton
quand on avait bac +1 plus doux plus
trois de cracher sur la soupe bernard
henri lévy et moi ça m'a intrigué parce
que j'étais pas bac + 3 buts et bach -3
et je trouvais ça trop lent et je
trouvais que cet unanimisme contre lui
était louche et moi j'aime bien ce que
décalés je trouve que bernard henri lévy
est un type comme d'autres d'ailleurs
qui sort de toutes les formes de
normalité ça ça m'intéresse et j'ai
voulu aller voir pourquoi alors voilà il
est à la fois un bouc émissaire c'est
facile de taper dessus parce qu'ils
passent beaucoup à la télévision et
qu'en plus je pense à une époque en tout
cas il a aimé ça et il sert aussi de
faire valoir dans certains cénacles où
pour se faire reconnaître ou élire de
ses propres camarades dont il est de bon
ton de dire que c'est une merde ouais
c'est un homme de pouvoir quand même de
pouvoir ce afin de pouvoir c'est un
homme qui est
la pensée le pouvoir c'est toujours mal
perçue mal vécu ce sens à l'écrivain des
gens vierge des gens compagne mains dans
les mains propres évidemment et puis on
se rend compte que l'un qui assume le
fait d'aimer le pouvoir d'y être parfois
et ça ça passe par semaine pourquoi
bernard henri lévy pourquoi pas
finkielkraut et
peut-être que moi j'ai 35 ans donc je
suis les piles en 68 on est une
génération
moyenne oui c'est ça médiocre on n'a pas
vécu grand chose on est une génération
en quête de son événement on ne trouve
pas alors on invente souvent ceux des
conneries c'est factice
et que lui incarner sans doute une
espèce de romantisme je sais que le mot
lui plairait pas à témoin c'est bien ça
témoigne à visage découvert ça t'a fait
du bien d'en parler tant les temps
centenaire ah là là je je je vis cette
émission comme une séance de psy toute
façon il doit tout recommencer
a commencé
alors ce qu'il faut dire aussi parce que
le livre est vraiment je le dis encore
une fois super bien écrit et c'est
difficile d'en parler mais avant de se
décider de devenir écrivain
fait un petit crochet par là par la
politique elles ont fait une description
très drôle du milieu politique c'est
assez c'est assez savoureux et un moment
jack lang vous dit au sujet de bernard
henri lévy j'aimerais avoir son talent
j'en ferai un meilleur usage il était
agacé de deux
succès de bernard henri lévy certaines
voulaient terry henri lévy est un type
quoi qu'on en pense qui depuis trente
ans et dans le paysage ouais il ya je
crois qu'il ya une semaine vous receviez
béglé sur ces débris htc la saison j'ai
vite et voilà on n'y peut rien on peut
le dégommer une fois on essaie une
deuxième fois une troisième fois il est
toujours là ça veut quand même dire
quelque chose inquiets qui chatouille
quelque part un tout petit peu il ya un
mot de cocteau qui y la mémoire qui dit
je crois les autres on l'est on les
envisage moi on me dévisage voilà c'est
je crois ce qui avait barré la vie on la
reconnaît son visage sa femme pourquoi
pas sa chemise énormément mais on n'a
pas envisagé autrement dit les gens qui
me taper dessus knees et moi je leur
disais tu allumes a demandé les vip
après il ya un livre qui sort ces
jours-ci c'est ça le truc avec lequel on
va parler c'est qu'il faut le lire
d'abord et fédrigo
et
un livre qui sort ces jours-ci d'un
penseur éminent marcel gaucher
je ne serais incapable d'assumer plus de
cinq minutes de discussion
sur 300 pages il ne trouve qu'une
histoire des intellectuels endroit il ya
un seul intellectuel qui le fait pouffer
de rire 30 ans sebban henri lévy qui
cale chila moi si j'avais son
intelligence tous les jours je pouffe
raid rire devant les tas de gens qui
sera clos le penseur pourquoi
l'acharnement ce qui est intéressant
c'est ça c'est pourquoi à partir de thé
est ce qu'on peut discuter on peut être
bhl yankee mâché lien c'est pas le sujet
pourquoi est-ce que à chaque fois pas
qu'il nous reste plus que ça en poche on
va le sortir et là c'est pratique voilà
alors vous décider ensuite de devenir
écrivain villemin d'écrire ce livre qui
vous mènera jusqu'à jusqu'à arielle
dombasle d'abord il vous dit c'est elle
qui m'a le plus appris sur bernard henri
lévy finalement mais c'est grave parce
qu'elle voit ans bernard henri lévy une
figure christique
je ne dis pas que c'est elle qui m'a le
plus appris ce qui m'a le plus de prix
de valeur henri lévy c'est mes lectures
de malheur je dis que c'est elle qui m'a
fourni à la fin de cette enquête c'est
d'une prétention de dire enquête qui m'a
fourni quelques mots pleins de poésie
plein de justesse à la fois plein de
distance et de retraits que moi en tant
que petit écrivaillons je n'avais pas je
ne trouvais pas voilà la fin du bouquin
donc vous allez à sarajevo parce qu'on
vise c'est quand même incroyable que
bernard lévy et dépenser autant
d'énergie autant de temps pour s'occuper
de la bosnie et vous retrouver quelqu'un
qui s'appelle samir qui là qu'il a
croisés en bosnie et visiteront enfin
pourquoi bernard henri lévy est venu là
pour quoi il a passé autant de temps à
faire tout ça est le type vous dit
bernard henri lévy m'a dit samir j'aime
la bosnie j'ai compris en y étant
comment on pouvait tomber amoureux de ce
pays voilà je sais pas seulement un
paysage s'est pas seulement des gueules
dans la rue c'est aussi il ya cette idée
du mélange qui est exceptionnel
exceptionnel on arrive sol et les petits
quartiers en autant de sarajevo il ya
une mosquée il ya un temple il ya une
église ils sont ensemble les gamins
jouent devant dans la rue sous le
souffle s'atténue en buvant du thé elle
dure quelques équipes à le tchador etc
personne ne dit rien ça rigole et ça se
marre je crois que bernard henri lévy a
fait ça et ça il le dit depuis 30 ans
une 25 ans c'est une de ces questions de
principe comme il digne de ses
obsessions on peut en avoir il à celle
ci qu'est la question du cosmopolitisme
on ne se résout pas à la à la fracture d
des mondes à l'établissement les
frontières etc derrière j'enchaîne vous
faites un magazine qui s'appelle toc la
société interviewé et le dossier premier
numéro c'est marre des tribus défendre
le métissage face au communautarisme
dont vous êtes bien dans ce
cosmopolitisme la saison qu'il en
parlait en tout cas même si vous êtes
vous si vous n'aimez pas le mot
révélations mais il ya une admiration
pour l'homme de télévision qui passe à
la télé vient d'abord et puis pour
l'écrivain et comme le dit thierry
jolibert je n'ai pas lu encore cissé
envie de le lire il est remarquablement
écrits et puis j'ai la presse vous dites
c'est votre première télé ce soir et
vous avez l'air d'en avoir fait saint
quentin mais la très protégé la mouche
11e de tat là il est un peu violent
parfois observé bernard henri lévy
de ce point de vue
yann parce qu'il ya cette gestuelle avec
la main par exemple que vous avez écrit
beaucoup aussi informations noir alors
que lui et blanc à la bourrin kopierre
disent merci
[Musique]
monsieur
c'est édité chez les messieurs
j'accueille notre temps lors garnier
alors agressé tout le monde vous êtes le
dj français le plus connu dans le monde
non je sais pas si vous le dis bah oui
c'est vrai je sais pas pour vous est
aussi musicien vous avez une victoire la
musique en 98 patron de fo communication
le plus célèbre label français de
musique électronique et vous publié chez
flammarion
électrochoc bien alors c'est ni votre
biographie ni l'histoire de la musique
techno mais un mix c'est normal bonton
j'ai donné vous êtes fait aider par un
journal il s'appelle david brin lambert
et c'est un petit peu un retour sur 15
ans de techno et puis un retour sur sur
vous-même en même temps et je dirais un
petit peu comme comme on l'a dit a beau
temps tout à l'heure une espèce de
thérapies non pour moi oui oui pour moi
ça a été une thérapie c'est vrai que
j'ai pu enfin me poser on m'a posé des
questions certes on a travaillé que
david pendant un an un an et demi sur ce
livre est la première année il m'a posé
énormément de questions forcément sur
toute ma carrière et c'est vrai qu'il ya
il ya un moment où j'ai dû j'ai dû
répondre à toutes ces questions et
comprendre un peu pourquoi je me suis
battu pour cette musique là eh oui ça a
été une espèce de terrain peer alors
pourquoi ai je fait danser mes parents
dans ma chatte de l'enfant voilà c'est
pas c'est la grande réponse qu'apporte
ce livre à l'avis de laurent garnier
alors votre premier contact avec la
musique si vous aviez des parents
forains mais on en perd deux premiers
contacts c'est la musique des autos
tamponneuses c'est à dire le la disco la
sole le fin que vous restez musique non
voilà
dix ans vous créer une mini discothèque
dans votre chambre ça c'est absolument
énorme c'est à dire avec la boule à
facettes avec le stroboscope la
palestine et des guitares en carton moi
j'avais j'avais tout tout tout le web ou
la façade 3
spot tout merdier quoi à 8 ans vous
faites des cassettes pour vos amis à
l'école à 12 ans quand vos parents
dorment vous allez devant la chaîne hi
fi vous mettez un casque vous écoutez de
la musique malienne j'enregistre
j'enregistre les cassettes pour savoir
ce qu'étaient les imports ce qu'à
l'époque c'était la grande époque des
impôts donc je découvrais la musique
comme ça à 14 ans vous créer une radio
pirate qui s'appelle radio teenagers
et puis votre premier choc musical en
fait vraiment c'est à rimini sur la côte
adriatique
vos parents vous emmène en vacances ce
soir ils ont déposé et yves votre frère
sur le parking d'un dancing et vous
entendez sortant de la discothèque
[Musique]
musique qui vous marquera à vie oui j'ai
touché toujours se disent dans mes
caisses de discrets toujours est il très
long giorgio moroder tout à fait normaux
parents veulent que vous aviez à l'école
vous fait école normale est normal
c est bien comme exercice normal yens 34
ans c'est autre chose donc vos parents
vous font faire l'école hôtelière est
alors très rigolo vous vous retrouvez
valet de pied intéresse la soirée at il
annoncé alors rigolo mois se retrouvent
value de l'anivin la saveur de france en
grande bretagne
[Rires]
c'est vrai
c'est bien deuxième
place et d'humour anglais en même temps
on va servir grande-bretagne valet de
pied de l'an passé vous piquez le
manteau de la reine d'angleterre comment
expliquer les bouteilles de don pérignon
pour les faire la fin ça c'est être con
ça me plaît de soirée avec le avec les
bouteilles de l'ambassadeur de france
ipic électoraux
et alors là au mudd club qui est un club
très célèbre de l'époque en angleterre
dans les consciences de votre vocation
c'est là où je découvre vraiment les djs
et la découvre que quelqu'un raconte une
histoire en jouant de la musique et
c'est là où je commence vraiment à
suivre suivre des gens quoi et alors
après l'ambassadeur votre pote
finalement de se donner un petit peu
votre pote
j'étais triste
il est remplacé cet ambassadeur et d'un
autre qui vient à sa place il avoue
porter à manchester où vous découvrez
l'hacienda et c'est là que tout commence
le club de tony wilson manager de joy
division et new order en pleine vague
acid house vous dit c'est quoi ce truc
même avancé à moi je suis arrivé un an
avant que cette musique explosé sac
le seul truc qui m'excitait un peu à
manchester s'était ce club scallon dont
je connaissais des dizaines de clubs
mais manchester n'y avait pas grand
chose mais avec d'énormes building qui
étaient là où tout se passait donc ouais
j'y allais souvent vous dit quelque
chose de brûlants venait d'entrer dans
ma vie la house music fils est ce que
les 10 6e défense beaucoup parce que
c'est vrai que là où la techno tout ça
c'est quand même lié aux aux
amphétamines alex tai s'est ralliée à sa
et non mais franchement la drogue y en a
il y en a dans la nuit depuis toujours
depuis la nuit des temps mais faut
arrêter de se faire l'amalgamme quand
c'est super chiant on entend ça tout le
temps c'est un peu fatiguant couet moi
je veux juste savoir est ce que quand au
moment où tu mets un disque que tu sais
ce que celui que tu mettras derrière
jamais jamais jamais jusqu à quel moment
tu mets un disque tu vas toujours
regarder ce qui se passe dans la salle
tu va regarder tapie c'était à partir de
là tu peux choisir si tu peux aller plus
loin ou si tu as été un petit peu trop
loin et c'est vraiment de
l'improvisation à chaque 10 tu sais
jamais où tu vas et cette improvisation
tu arrives à la recréer chaque soir bas
tous les soirs on change d'histoire en
même temps dès lors que tu te verrai ce
plan des gens viennent te voir comment
il va le spectacle donc tu leur propose
une musique ce sont des chasseurs ont
aujourd'hui on va voir un dj comment va
voir un concert spécial donc scellé des
bus qui doivent être difficile quand tu
vois qu'on peut être les gens qui
viennent aussi si je comprends
c'est l'un des meilleurs dj du mais
voilà d'humour est le mével et des buts
nos garnier merci mes toiles à et
j'accueille maintenant thierry gandillot
[Musique]
c'est bien je dis bonjour non voilà
thierry gandillot bonsoir vous êtes cet
acteur en chef des pages culture de
l'express auteur d'un certain nombre
d'essai conomique est spécialisé depuis
quelques années dans le roman noir
chenil vous avez publié l'héritage
rinspeed la chambre de barbe bleue
câline chez robert laffont vous avez
publié code vaudou et aujourd'hui vous
publiez les locataires alors c'est un
thriller sacré très bien construit qui
se passe dans un milieu parisien
pourri par le blé obsédé par le sexe et
c'est une espèce de guarding portrait
comme ça au au vitriol de la société
contemporaine le personnage central qui
s'appelle robert de niro mais d eux n y
ait pas eu d et son envie d'apporter
voilà son homonymie est un petit peu
gênante quand maintenant mais je
j'en ai marre des tips dans les dents
dans les polars s'appelait toujours un
petit peu la même façon des noms un peu
neutre cas où bon et nous y tiendrons à
propos charger chercher un nom comme
tout le monde a au début et puis tout
d'un coup ses soutiens mais si au fond
il avait déjà une fêlure une taie truc
un truc un truc a dû rapporter ce que
c'est un type à un exécuteur des basses
besognes expulseurs va parler et donc
j'y tiens c'est comment on fait quand on
s'appelle robert de niro quand on se
présente pour virer les gens d'un
immeuble voilà bonjour je m'appelle
robert de niro
ce robert de niro effectivement il
travaille dans l'immobilier
son boulot c'est de vider des locataires
des immeubles achetés par sa société et
depuis que sa femme l'a quitté en
amenant leur fille il est devenu méchant
ouais il fallait qu'il avait une petite
prédispositions quand même mais ça l'a
rendu encore plus méchant et surtout
encore plus efficace il ne fait plus que
deux choses dans la vie virer les gens
des immeubles et écouter maurice andré
trompez pas il les adore maurice
andrieux le site avait quand même du
maurice andré pour écrire le livre
alessandra mais c'est quand même pas
bons ils sont restés sans cesser le roi
de la trompette non ils sont
célèbres d'ailleurs il a des joues des
auteurs absolument inconnu est très
sophistiqué donc ce robert de niro non
seulement il est méchant bien parce que
sa femme l'a quitté en amenant leurs
films et en plus il est très jaloux des
privilèges des des pontes des grands
pontes de sa société oui c'est à dire
qu'en fait il vient d'un milieu très
modeste il a vu son père - danse d'une
usine après avoir inhalé des produits
d'effets à zéro si je vais m'en sortir
et donc donc il a un boulot qui a cassé
craque quand même mais et hilton un coup
il s'aperçoit que les gens qui sont au
dessus de celui gagne beaucoup plus
d'argent il entend un mot qui le fascine
c'est big money la cire que lui la
déprime mais il n'a pas dans la big mais
là il est sorti son milieu il a vraiment
où il ay là il a une voiture de marque
je ne serais pas ici elle arriva il
arrivé là des beaux costards et tout
mais il voit tout d'un coup de ce mot de
big money et ça ça le fait absolument
fantasmes et il voit qu'en fait en gros
il faut rajouter un ou 2 0
voilà là il s'appelle sulitzer la lui il
va arriver ce qui à valmorel et dont ils
font des pauses et d'icônes en
saskatchewan les choses
tiens un petit écart là je vais aussi
les les cartes la société que vous
décrivez dans ce bouquin est absolument
effectivement pourri par le blay obsédé
par le sexe est plus fait c'est un peu
une satire sociale et j'avais envie
quand même aussi de pas mal de dénoncer
tous les gens qui eux par exemple
achète une usine la ferme pendant l'été
vandal ans quand les à chiner quand les
mecs arrivent les 15 centimes par
exemple vous êtes tour dé quoi c'est un
petit peu savent montrer que ya eu des
gens qui dont c'est le métier alors donc
ce robert de niro au début du livre
s'attaque à un immeuble bourgeois du 15e
il doit donc virer les locataires pour
que la société puisse leur revente de
faire une plus-value voilà alors celui
de même beaucoup et ouais les arrêts
habituels ces menaces chantages violence
oui c'est ça alors il est il était il
est quand même assez sophistiqué donc il
est il essaie d'abord de comprendre
l'âme de l'immeuble de ses lecteurs dans
sa phase tout dans un seul immeuble et
donc de comprendre un petit peu quels
sont les figures de chacun quels sont
les oui c'est extrêmement voilà c'est le
mot c'est exactement ça il est
extrêmement pervers très malin et donc
ils rentrent petit à petit il dit pas
que c'est lui le nouveau proprio etc
simplement il commence à inspecter
regarder un peu partout et est rentré un
petit peu dans la vie privée des gens
avec des méthodes qui sont limite
excusions assis là où c'est intéressant
parce que c'est exactement qui sont ces
gens qu'on croise tous les jours dans
l'escalier lui il est obligé de le faire
plus on s'en fout mais il est obligé de
le faire parce que pour les virer il
faut qu'ils trouvent leur leurs
faiblesses leurs fêlures et sa wii donc
c'est en fait c'est un type qui va qui
capable de rentrer dans les chambres de
bonne pour aller vérifier si le type du
rez de chaussée ne n'en profite pas pour
faire des après midi avec ça avec son
assistante et justement ya gilbert le
kiné volet heures mais son assistante
nadel un champ de ciney end dernier tout
cet attirail cours d'eau assez
sophistiqué d'ailleurs dans la chambre
de sixième alors il ya clip le designer
automobile qui est dingue
c'est très caricatural est très très
bien vu où il est devenu fou de de
bouddhisme sa femme le fait plus bon
jury là oui c'est ça oui il ya alors un
jeu un jour il a hissé il a eu une
phrase qui lui a été dit par les
designers automobiles donc chez renault
et il ya un peu un type de la fiat qui
lui a dit une chose extraordinaire
l'homme de la main existe depuis vingt
mille ans et les poignées de portes
change toutes les trois minutes qu à
chaque modèle non et ça cette phrase si
la troïka un peu de lahoud seul adhérent
quoi il sait comment ça fantasmes et là
dessus et il se lance dans le bouddhisme
et manon savard le terme islam est très
très mal contrairement à ce que dit
mathieu ricard lou 10 ne mène pas
toujours au bonheur là on le sait ce
qu'on doit effectivement dans votre
bouquin effectivement lors il ya michel
sa femme qui est très adepte des plans
et c'est malheureux à dire que lui
s'occupe de la plus belle du thym et
donc elle elle a envie de 2,2
d'abord de réussir dans la vie et des
queues et donc elle va trouver quelqu'un
veut lui faire à la fois gagner beaucoup
d'argent et en même temps effectivement
d après midi
sophistiqué c'est l'entente vous voient
comme ça jerry perrault directeur des
pages culturelles express vous avez
l'air plutôt bien et toupie alors quand
on lit quand on lit le bouquin dit danse
c'est drôlement salle est quand même
assez assez salée je veux dire je me
suis quand même beaucoup beaucoup marié
à l'écrire ouais ouais c'est vraiment
que chanter pour eux j'ai fait un bon
goût la page j'ai trouvé dans un journal
will say they dégâts des ya déjà des
après-midis tupperware révélé quand les
dames se vont les unes chez les autres
et là il y en a avec avec des godemichés
figurez-vous avec voilà voilà thierry
gandillot ya germaine la vieille
communiste qui élèvent des lévriers il
ya luisao la mère de famille qui
découvre qu'elle est lesbienne enfin
c'est un monde comme cela c'est qu'ils
n'en fait en fait l'idée c'est que notre
fameux pervers robert de niro qui
pensent qu'il a son petit monde à sa
main qu'il avait toutes les enquêtes
qu'il fallait la trouver vraiment les
plans pourraient vraiment tous les
avoirs en fait s'ils sont tous sont au
moins aussi tordu que lui mais eux ils
n'ont pas de plan mais ils sont vraiment
traiteur dhuisy ils vont ils vont le
rendre dingue quoi en faire et puis il
ya david l'écrivain érotomane et dealers
ça c'est le personnage dont je suis le
plus le plus intéressant lui l'implant
un mois que je sois vraiment génial
c'est que comme on lui demande d'écrire
des livres érotiques un petit peu un peu
soft il comme il en a marre il est cuit
quand même il n'a pas envie de passer sa
vie à ça il a une bible qui est un livre
qui existe un livre du 19e siècle qui
s'appelle ma vie secrète par des
anonymes c'est à dire qu'il fait 5000
pages blessé mais que du cul du début
jusqu'à la fin type dix neuvième siècle
un onglet c'est absolument
invraisemblable alors comme pour pas se
fatiguer va prendre des passages et puis
les remet dans ses bouquins alors ça se
passe sous d'autres à ses souhaits à
buenos aires pendant la paire du tango
ça peut se passer dans la mitteleuropa
etc et à chaque fois il reprend les
éditions jets personnes ascough commune
aussi les premiers avec lennon quand la
sat 1 en 8e le repas il va prendre vie
prend les équipes de football la
bundesliga ils volent et on mélange un
mélange souffrance ou franz beckenbauer
extraordinaire alors dernière question
pourquoi le livre est dédié adamo lits
dédiés adamo parce que pour deux raisons
la première c'est que c'est mon ami gay
et que je n'en avais dix ans j'ai avec
mon premier argent de noël j'ai acheté
le premier descendant des 160 3 j'ai
acheté le premier vinyle d'adamo et que
j'ai eue le p2 en fait pour le ch l'a
rencontré il ya cinq ans et vraiment
c'est un type exceptionnel j'ai vu à
votre émission semaine à faire regarder
et
un mot fait des doigts d'honneur dans
tout le monde en parle j'ai un petit
clin d'oeil dans le dans le livre
puisque le taux plein au japonais oui le
fameux dealer de coke d'ailleurs et il
adore tombe la neige et il connaît tombe
la neige ont chacun japonais lassés
souviens d'un jour où une fille c'est
christian jolibois foule ou anne
hathaway connaît et c'est pas lui qui
tombe pas des jeux qui est au dernier
m
et maintenant le blade est
[Applaudissements]
ce soir j'accueille aux platines mon
cher philippe portier
alors non vie voilà ça fait du bien de
revenir à la maison oui alors atteint
j'ai une surprise pour toi c'est quoi je
peux refaire et d'entrée oui j'ai deux
bombes oui alors libre
[Musique]
ou analysis d'abdellaoue granby rajhi
mais toi rapproche toi de laurent mais
toi entre laurent et voilà entre laurent
et bruno bonsoir mes demoiselles bombe
d'accord je vois pas les oreilles un
show voit que quand il se promène
toujours avec deux bonds basse alors
puisque tous les soirs les corses vous
connaissez le principe du blind test je
veux l'interprète fit passer près
[Musique]
bien efficacement
ça fait un point b l'équipe de hélène
ségara c'était des finances
axelrod
alors toi aussi
voilà merci philippe oui
[Musique]
cameron ces longues années
non
spécial garnier voilà c'était pour garni
la trouverez d'ailleurs cet effet pour
lui film
sega
maison
voilà donc ça fait 3 points pour
l'équipe d'hélène ségara zéro point non
mais depuis que c'est plus ma femme qui
fait le blind test s'ils trouvent une
réponse
j'attends mon ami pascal sellem pour
jouer ainsi que des trucs de gouache
excuses mais nous sommes assez bons vous
êtes à 3 0 donc on y va philippe
attention numéro 5
les déjà patent ses lauriers bien
répondu
et même si c'est lui c'est à moi ki moon
on parle de musique là d'accord lors
musique tu penses que ta répandue avant
l'on regarde le nom là là je m'en mets
alors m contre food de savoir avant
après mais je suis content d'avoir
trouvé un gpu qui rêvant de problèmes et
j'étais content on peut voir
[Musique]
la
psychiatre serge
avec ecône ans après en avoir partout
méricain voilà très bien je sais pas
j'ai vu la liste même en lui c'est donc
en merde c'est facile attention philippe
rey patron
[Musique]
hier
bah
wardy
comment s'appelle ton ami juste une
question bon bah ça va ouais et amalia
filet
[Musique]
ouais
là
c'est non
attention bravo hélène non mais sérieux
parce que quand tu arrives au motif que
je m'énerve je suis restée toute
l'émission rien que pour ça tous les
samedis je regarde si l'étude de steevy
boulay trouver l'addition
à windows 7 c'était il ya un mois et
demi je n'avais rien aussi
attention philippe
[Musique]
on écrit
lcl est en train d'exploser est en train
d'exploser belle fille hélène ségara
zenonia la partie on a le choix ici
c'est vraiment te faire exploser par et
si j'en rêvais thierry la finale mais
attention fip
annie lennox featuring redman
[Musique]
et maintenant on en arriver là série des
banques qu donc il ya plus d'équipés
chacun pour sa gueule firme c'est
l'ultra libéralisme c'est la jungle
c'est alain madelin mais thirion zioui
une règle oui j'ai dit tu peux jouer
aussi bien sûr judicieux jouer eh bien
cela ne peut jouer allons-y c'est très
très dur
coup là franchement je suis là mais
attention
[Musique]
la révélation
le grand vainqueur est notre tagueurs
ramzy et l'équipe gagnante c'est celle
d'hélène ségara
[Applaudissements]
c'était tout le monde en parle avec
monsieur
jean pierre
son coeur a dit shero
giresse
boutique de tony marshall avec gilles
gaudreau h karin viard françois cusset
bernard menez micheline presle hélène
fillières die die sortie le 29 octobre
bruno solo et yvan le bolloc'h la bd
caméra café sortie le 3 novembre et le
coffret dvd caméra café l'intégrale de
jane est sorti le 21 octobre et la
fiction fausses urgences de police la
durée du lundi au vendredi à 19h50 c'est
sur france 2 et ça commence ce lundi via
comme chez apple humaine en tournée des
formes innovantes à l'olympia en apporte
les filles et les femmes bush
13e rang william reymond billy célestine
tiers qu est le dernier témoin c'est
chez flammarion philippe et boushaba 2
comme tous du chat chez casterman le
chien s'expose aux beaux-arts de paris
du 28 octobre au 4 janvier 2004 pierre
botton j'aime la vie comment remonter la
pente
c'est chez flammarion dave gahan album
s'appelle l'hyper monsters
le single s'appelle
idiot il est en concert le 20 novembre
au zénith et le dvd depeche mode one on
one sort le 10 novembre
monsieur lévy chez plon rédacteur en
chef adjoint
[Musique]
cochon avec david rolland berger de la
mariant le coffret de 3 cd lors garnier
excess le guen cheval à thierry
gandillot les locataires chez robert
laffont philippe corti la pomme
adieu après 27 jours
les reporters sans frontières mais en
bon droit car andriot prix de plus
l'euro en profite
emprisonné dans le monde de l'art
c'était que mon enfant rendez vous la
semaine prochaine
des champions grâce à son père qui n'est
pour rien dans la logique des faits le
field goal de boer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ban
sur le choix des matières cachette et
c'est pourquoi dès ce mois après le thé
vert est là dans la tête d'ivan de
l'opéra quand on lui qu'avec on voit
paris ça fait gagner des millions les
pelles coller aux virages ce hashtag est
en location
que ya un
petit temps et en heure
[Musique]
plus de chance
je
[Musique]
ban
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu